exquisite so genau ach es ist ja jetzt ich es ist ja september schon seit 20 20 tagen ich hab
nur mal wieder nichts mitgekriegt von leute wisst ihr was das schlimme ist 14 monate 15
15 monate hyper subscription hier was das schlimme ist ich habe es halt irgendwie habe ich euch ja
schon mal erzählt ich weiß nicht also ich glaube nicht dass ich wirklich corona habe ja ich meine
ich bin doppelt geimpft seit ein paar wochen also das sollte eigentlich nichts passieren man weiß
ja nie man weiß ja nie ich wusste ich muss seit zwei wochen die ganze zeit irgendwie wussten also
alles komisch und sagt so komisches zu komisches corona husten mäßig ohne dass das irgendwie so
trocken wisst ihr ja monka es aber ansonsten merke ich nix wo ich einfach mehr trinken
ja
leute ich habe dieses jahr darauf verzichtet die apple konferenz zu streamen ich habe keinen bock
dass mich apple für kostenlose werbung noch mal strikt sonst hätte ich das gestreamt das war ja
aber nicht sonderlich viel spannendes dabei habe ich gesehen genau wir lassen uns von level cap
g baden wieder sieht's aus mal gucken ob es überhaupt gibt übrigens wer so nicht mitgekriegt
hat wahrscheinlich haben sie alle mit mitgekriegt battlefield wurde wenn viel 20 42 wurde verschoben
ja schon ein paar mal im stream gesagt dass ich mir vorstellen könnte dass das passiert ich meine gut ich
sage viel im stream wenn der tag lang ist was passieren könnte und die hälfte davon oder
aber acht prozent davon passiert dann auch nicht aber immerhin ich habe es euch gesagt ja das neue
iphone ist sowieso ein witz warum ich habe mich damit null beschäftigt was ist denn das ist 13
wahrscheinlich ne was ist denn die größte enttäuschung ist nicht chip chip okay okay
wir werden uns jetzt mal die fachmännische also einfach die herausragende expertise von chip an
was sagt was sagt chip denn dazu also wenn es einmal sind wir uns einig dann ist es chip apple
hat auf der kino das war ja bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla team apple war auch wieder am
start wäre es sonst okay also was was gibt es noch mit hochauflösenden kameras einem schnelleren chip
Und mehr Akkuleistung sind sicherlich moderner, besser aufregend als die Smartphones.
Neue Erfahrungen gibt es auch, okay, Mitternacht und Polarstern, gut, das kann er benamen, kann Apple ja immer prinzipiell gut.
Trotzdem hat man als Apple-Fan am Ende irgendwie mehr erwartet, Quatsch, Apple-Fans, Apple-Fans freuen sich über alles, was da so hingeschmissen wird.
Apple-Fans kannst du auch sagen, hey, ihr könnt euch jetzt einen virtuellen Fussel von, oder ihr könnt euch einen Fussel kaufen von Tim Cooks Hemd,
äh, von der letzten Keynote und die Leute rennen dahin, das juckt die doch überhaupt nicht.
Trotzdem hat man als Apple-Fan am Ende irgendwie mehr erwartet.
Ja, ich frag mich, ich frag mich nur, was? Das ist ja eh der Witz, ne, bei jeder Keynote der letzten, keine Ahnung, 5 Jahre,
haben die Leute gesagt, ah, die hat, hat mich jetzt ganz schön enttäuscht, die Apple-Keynote.
Ich mein, wir haben uns im Stream jetzt öfters angeguckt und das ging uns ja mehr oder weniger auch fast jedes Mal so.
Und die, die, das ist ja nicht die, äh, welche, welche, welche Apple-Keynote?
Apple-Präsentation war das jetzt eigentlich?
Ich blick da nicht mehr durch, die haben ja 2, 3 im Jahr.
Also, also langsam, aber sicher sollte man das doch vielleicht lernen, dass man da nicht so viel erwartet.
Außerdem, jetzt mal im Ernst, was sollen die denn großartig machen?
Die können ja schlecht, die können ja schlecht ein neues Smartphone, also die können ja schlecht jährlich so was erfinden wie im Kaliber von,
wir erfinden quasi mal im Alleingang ein Smartphone.
Und ja, ich weiß, Apple hatte nicht das erste Smartphone, Apple hatte aber das erste halbwegs benutzbare Smartphone für die Masse.
Ne?
Es gab ja so Dinger wie Nokia Kommuni...
Kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch diese Dinger?
Nokia Communicator, diese alten Dinger, diese fetten, diese Dinger.
Natürlich, das war auch ein Smartphone, aber das kannst du nicht, das kannst du nicht mal ernsthaft mit dem allerersten Smartphone, äh, mit dem ersten, äh, iPhone vergleichen.
Ähm, das ist...
Mein Cool ist, es hat eine Tastatur gehabt.
Genau.
Ja, seh ich, seh ich genauso.
Kaufst du dir ein iPhone 13?
Ne, kauf ich nicht.
Ich kauf mir gar keine iPhones.
Ich hab das Glück, oder das Pech, ja, das kann man jetzt sehen, wie man will, ähm, dass ich, dort, wo ich arbeite, krieg ich alle 1-2 Jahre ein neues iPhone-Modell.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bedarf für Smartphones, aber ich hab einige andere Apple-Geräte.
Also, ich hab meiner Mutter damals ein iPhone SE gekauft und wir haben zwei, zwei iPads, aber ich hab halt immer nur ein iPhone, das war's gerade, so die letzte Generation.
Aber ich bin gerade am überlegen.
Alter, ich muss die ganze Zeit husten.
Das ist schlimm, vielleicht hab ich doch Corona.
Ah, so.
So, also, Apple-Fan, wo sind die, auch, bla, bla, bla.
Boah, wie viel kostet das?
Na gut, Terabyte.
Das ist eh so ein Ding, ne, mal ganz im Ernst.
Also, wer sich, wer sich Speicherplatz in nem, in nem Handy oder in nem iPad kauft, der ist eh nicht mehr zu retten.
Die kleinste Ausführung reicht in der Regel.
Ich mein, die wissen ja auch schon, warum es keine Micro-SD-Karte mehr gibt.
Aber, die machen mit dem Speicher so unglaublich viel Reibach, das ist nicht mehr normal.
Das, das steht in...
Ab, das steht in Null, in absolut gar keinem Verhältnis, was die Speicher-Upgrades kosten.
Wenn du geimpft bist, sind die Tests kostenlos.
Ich hab sogar noch einen Test unten liegen, hier.
Naso-Check.
Naso-Check-Comfort, Alter.
Hab ich unten liegen.
Beim Lidl gab's den, genau, hier, den da.
Könnt ich mir mal in die Nase schieben, schnell.
Wir machen jetzt live, live Corona-Test, Alter.
Äh.
Machen wir nicht.
Hahaha.
Schnell und angenehm.
Einfache Anwendung im Vordergrund.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so angenehm ist.
Ja, na gut.
Ähm, so, und ansonsten sind die Leute halt enttäuscht.
Ja gut, who cares, ne?
Interessiert mich jetzt nicht so.
Was mich viel mehr interessiert ist,
ich will das nicht vorbestellen,
kann auch sein, dass du die Grippe bekommst.
Nee, das wird sich anders anfühlen.
Dann hätte ich Fieber.
Aber so richtig, nee, nee.
Ähm.
Was ich viel interessanter finde, ist jetzt,
da muss ich, da, im Chat, da muss ich euch mal fragen, was ihr zu denkt,
weil wir wissen ja, der Chat hat prinzipiell ja von allem, von allem, äh, immer Ahnung.
Das wissen wir ja.
Also, ähm,
würdet ihr euch jetzt noch ein iPhone 11 kaufen?
Als Upgrade für nen iPhone SE, erste, äh, first generation.
Warum ist denn die Seite so kacke, dass man hier nicht scrollen kann?
Äh.
Kann ich denn hier, äh.
Weil das Gute ist,
ja, als Upgrade für das iPhone SE von meiner Mutter.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich denn ein iPhone 11 kaufe.
Würde es gar keinen, ja, das ist jetzt auch egal.
Aber, ich mein, das ist jetzt billiger.
Es ist, hat ein größeres Bild-Display als das SE, die sieht nicht mehr so gut, ja.
Ansonsten ist ja, da, ansonsten ist das ja absolut in Ordnung, das iPhone 11.
Ja.
Passt mal auf.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Product Red, gelb.
Banane.
Ja, weiß, violett, ne, ne, ne.
Guck mal, warum gibt's das nicht mit, na gut, 32G ist tatsächlich ein bissl wenig.
Aber der, das Upgrade ist so krass teuer.
Guck mal, die wolle 50 Euro.
Übrigens auch geil, wie sie den Preis, wie sie es wegscrollen, wenn du es einmal angeklickt hast, ne.
Musst immer wieder, musst immer wieder hochscrollen.
Die wollen 50 Euro für 64G.
64G MicroSD krieg ich für 2,50 Euro.
Oder?
Oder sowas.
Gut, wahrscheinlich ist der Speicher ein bissl schneller als MicroSD.
Aber ne ordentliche MicroSD, das würde, würde voll und ganz reichen.
Ja, aber das wollen die ja nicht.
Hast du ein iPhone zum Eintauschen?
Ja.
Aber das zählt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Ich hab nen iPhone, äh, SE, erste Generation.
Ne, das zählt nicht mehr.
Blö.
Das ist Recycling.
Ne, ne.
Das hat Apple wirklich wahnsinnig gut drauf.
Ähm.
Das hat Apple wahnsinnig gut drauf, dass die es schaffen, dass du auf die Seite gehst und 579 Euro siehst hier und am Ende landest du beim kleinsten iPhone.
Von 13 für 900 oder so.
Das, das können die wirklich wahnsinnig gut.
Ja.
Ich meine 579 Euro geht ja eigentlich.
Das hätte ich zwar nie gedacht, dass ich früher, dass ich mal sagen würde, das ist ja ein ganz so, ganz normaler Preis für ein Smartphone.
Damals waren so, äh, die Topmodelle für 580 Euro, aber eigentlich geht das doch durchaus in Ordnung.
Marketing durchgespielt, ja.
Was kostet ne 64G MicroSD gerade?
Ja, nix.
Nix.
Gut, weil das kann man, das ist unfair, das jetzt so zu vergleichen.
Das normale 12er ist viel besser.
Ja gut, das normale 12er kostet aber auch wieder 100 Euro mehr.
Und schon haben sie es wieder geschafft.
Schon haben sie es wieder geschafft, dass du 250 Euro mehr ausgibst, als du eigentlich willst.
Ne, das ist, das ist schon.
Die, die haben das drauf, ja.
Nein, deswegen, ich glaube der 11er ist, 11er ist ganz gut.
Zumal, Moment, die, ist das eigentlich so, dass das iPhone SE erste Generation, dass die kein iOS 15 mehr kriegen?
Wenn die nämlich, ach, Moment mal, die kriegen, kriegen die noch iOS 15?
Aha.
Ja gut, theoretisch könnte ich dann auch noch nen Jahr warten.
Weil ich mein, der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich denn ein iPhone 11 kaufen will, ist, weil es keine Updates mehr gibt für das iPhone SE 1.
Aber wenn's noch, also gut, ich meine das Display.
Der ist auch fuddelig vom, vom ersten SE.
Aber trotzdem, da könnte man eigentlich noch ein Jahr warten.
Da kriegt man wahrscheinlich noch ein besseres Smartphone für noch weniger Geld.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich mein, es spricht auch nix dagegen, jetzt nen 11er zu kaufen eigentlich.
Na egal, wurscht.
Ne, die 6er Technik kann's nicht sein.
Das 6er war noch 32 Bit.
Das, das, ähm, SE ist schon 64 Bit.
Hier ist eine nice Übersicht der Modelle.
Die haben aber auch zu allem irgendwelche Statistiken, oder?
How long does Apple support older iPhone Models?
Ja, hier, guck.
Das ist, das siehst du, das ist ab der 64 Bit Umstellung.
Die 64 Bit Umstellung kriegt das.
Aber das ist schon wirklich in Ordnung.
Also, das sind dann 7 Jahre 2022 Support.
Da kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Natürlich kann man sagen, wozu, wenn das noch voll und ganz tut.
Sehe ich ja irgendwo auch so.
Warum braucht man was Neues, wenn das noch vollkommen in Ordnung ist, das alte Zeug.
Aber da sind wir wieder beim gleichen Problem.
Was soll Apple jedes Jahr ein tolles Neues vorstellen?
Die können das Ding ein bisschen schneller machen.
Die können dem Ding vielleicht noch eine bessere Kamera produzieren.
Aber man muss sagen, so die Mainstream Smartphones, also Geräte, so Mainstream Geräte wie Smartphones, das ist mittlerweile so gut ausgebaut.
Du, eigentlich braucht man...
gar kein Neues für einige Jahre mehr.
Ich meine, wozu?
Wozu willst du neue iPhones, oder wozu willst du dir ein neues Smartphone kaufen?
Also, das Einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt, ist vielleicht irgendwelche 5G-Geschichten.
Wobei man sich da auch einfach für impfen lassen kann.
Vielleicht, wenn man 5G hat oder WiFi 6 oder sowas, wenn das unbedingt, unbedingt sein muss.
Aber ansonsten, mir fällt da ehrlich gesagt nicht viel ein, wofür man denn ein neues Smartphone bräuchte.
Es fehlt der nächste große Schritt, was auch immer das sein soll.
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Ja.
Der nächste große Schritt, ich prophezei' euch das jetzt ehma'.
Also, vielleicht nicht der nächste große Schritt, aber einer der nächsten Schritte wird irgendetwas aus China sein.
Irgendeine chinesische Geschichte, die sich da übelst durchsetzt und dann auch mal zu uns rüber schwappt.
Was auch immer das sein wird.
Aber ich kann's mir gut vorstellen, weil die Zeiten,
wo man sich so...wo man so gelacht hat über China,
dass man sagt hey die können ja nur sachen kopieren oder die können ja nur sachen billig
herstellen das ist ja schon lange vorbei also die chinesen können natürlich immer noch wunderbar
sachen kopieren und sachen billig herstellen ich meine erinnert sich da noch jemand daran wo ich
meinen controller hier abgefackelt hat mit billig china spannungswandler muss schön schön geraucht
hat das können die nach wie vor gut aber die können auch richtig gute sachen herstellen
man guckt mal beispielsweise was staubsauger roboter angeht das sind die schaumi geräte
eigentlich somit das beste klar gibt es gibt es schon noch vergleichbar aber somit das beste was
es gibt und dass ich china chinesen kram ja aber du kannst ja echt nicht beschweren wie lange das
ganze ab denn guck mal hier dass das se hat hat von ios 9 bis ios 15 das hat 16 updates gekriegt
und 2016 kam das ganze raus das ist sechs jahre alt nächstes jahr
also das ist doch da ist doch echt in ordnung kurz chat gucken immerhin alle drei jahre eine
neue smartphone kann ich mir vorstellen ja warum nicht warum nicht also ich kriege ungefähr alle
zwei jahre neues also im prinzip kriege ich immer von der arbeit die aktuelle bisschen budget
variante also ich hatte jetzt den iphone xr und habe dieses jahr den iphone 11 gekriegt das heißt
krieg dann wahrscheinlich in zwei jahren ein iphone 13 oder so vermute ich mal
also da muss ich mir keine gedanken waren eine berufsschule ist sehr kacke
es sind gibt es irgendwelche berufsschulen die nicht kacke sind ich
glaube die meisten sind kacke was passiert mit den alten phones er die
musik zurückgeben die sind nur geliest haben deshalb erklärt lassen vor allem
sind nur geliest und wenn ich wenn ich zu lange brauche das umzuziehen dann
müssen die überziehungsgebühren bezahlen ich habe das letzte mal vom xe
auf mann elfer habe ich irgendwie ein halbes jahr gebraucht weil ich den sinn
nicht gesehen habe zum upgrade hat mir der übelst lange zeit gelassen und
irgendwann ruft mich einer an von unserem mobile device zeug und regt sich
regt sich ein bisschen auf warum ich zurückgeschickt habe sagt hey warum
schmeißt das zeug doch weg da meinte nene das ist geliest jetzt müssen
überziehungsgebühren bezahlen ja benutzt du mera krypt ja warum willst du was
wissen bei deiner berufsschule hat sich die dämmung in der fassade spontan
selbst hat ja mal hoffentlich kein
amt
also wenn das so weiter vielleicht sogar noch das erste generation se dann 16 oder
sowas übrigens das ist auch so ein thema da könnte ich mich wahnsinnig drüber
aufregende also jetzt nicht unbedingt nicht nicht nicht wirklich so bezogen
jetzt auf auf iphones sondern allgemein wie kurzlebig wie kurzlebig steckt der
kram ist tastatur im arsch gewesen die letzte die ich hatte komplett doppelte
anschläge gehabt dann zwischendrin logitech tastatur gehabt control taste abgebrochen
abgebrochen ich müsste es erst mal schaffen dass die control taste abbricht so
neue logitech tastatur gekriegt maus doppelte links klicks gehabt warum ist
es jetzt so laut doppelte links klicks gehabt ausgetauscht das zeug ist alles
so ein schrott sogar meine heizung sogar meine heizung ist kaputt gegangen nach
paar jahren jetzt also nicht nicht nicht einfach die heizung das mainboard falscher feuerstoff
das mainboard meiner heizung ist kaputt gegangen ich wusste gar nicht dass meine
heizung überhaupt ein mainboard hat das mainboard meiner heizung ist kaputt gewesen
das muss ich dann irgendwie für 600 euro austauschen lassen das hat absolut kein
grund warum das so teuer sein muss alles billig china chinesen zeug
deswegen ist halt die sache das ist eh alles billig china kacke warum soll ich
nicht einfach billig china kacke billig selbst kaufen wenn es doch eh billig china kacke ist wisst ihr was ich mein
wisst ihr was ich mein
übrigens meine aliexpress bestellung ist da meine aliexpress bestellung ist da und
zwar ich hatte mir hier eine hausnummer bestellt ich so was hier ich glaube das
wird das ein ich hatte mir hausnummern bestellt mit mit led wobei ich die nicht
die nicht die eingebaute led verwenden will sondern ich mache da eine eigene
eigene led strip rein das ist dass es so ausschaut guckt guckt ich will dass meine
hausnummer so aussieht es nicht da ist das legal klar warum nicht du musst
einfach eine hausnummer haben ist das nichtının
das ist das nicht pounding podcast hausnummer ja und die habe ich mir bestellt die kam jetzt an und bereits
die hab ich mir bestellt die kam jetzt an und entgegen der ganzen befürchtungen
er muss das hier übrigens nicht so machen also man kann das ya mit led
einstellen wie man will das ist jetzt hier das jetzt einfach nur bisschen tschau was er hier macht was люди hier die nicht usw machen hier Streaming mit seguir
das ist jetzt hier das jetzt einfach nur bisschen show was was er hier macht was was man da im chat lag jetzt okay vielleicht fårnt sie sich jetzt nicht mit hier Issso vomlettrrum das sind wieder mehr in die chinesen die sich hier hier usw machen
was es damit geht.
Aber es hat schon was.
Es hat schon was, ne?
Zumindest ist es jetzt angekommen.
Und entgegen der Befürchtungen,
die der Chat hatte,
oder beziehungsweise die irgendwie
fast jeder mittlerweile hat, ist das Zeug
angekommen, ohne jegliche
Probleme, was Zoll,
Versand oder sonst was angeht.
Ich hab das bestellt.
Ja, zack, zack.
Ich glaub, ich weiß nicht mehr,
welche Größe ich bestellt hab.
Ich glaub 20 cm.
Nicht mit DHL für 48 Euro.
Sondern ich hab ganz normal bestellt.
Standard Shipping.
Und das kam jetzt an
vor einer Woche.
Bei AliExpress muss man jetzt auch Mehrwertsteuer zahlen.
Ja, meinetwegen ist...
Ja gut, wenn du auf Deutsch stellst.
Du kannst natürlich auch einfach
hier auf Afghanistan oder so stellen.
Lass mal kurz gucken,
was bestellen denn Afghanen aktuell so?
Vielleicht kugelsichere,
Westen oder so. Weiß nicht.
Haben die sowas?
Haben die sowas bei AliExpress?
Ah, guck mal, die liefern sogar nach Afghanistan.
Aber da musst du keine
Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen.
Wie nennt sich das denn auf Englisch?
Kugelsichere Weste.
Wie heißt denn das?
Security West oder irgendwie sowas?
Äh, Bulletproof.
Okay, mal gucken, ob es sowas
hier zu kaufen gibt bei...
Die China-Chinesen.
Kugelsichere West.
Ob ich mich darauf verlasten würde?
Hahaha.
Bin ich...
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Technical West...
What the fuck?
Warum kann ich Panzerplatten kaufen?
Naja, gut, ich mein...
Das ist hier wohl...
Was kostet das in Euro?
Das ist überhaupt nach Deutschland liefert.
Nicht, dass ich auch nur ansatzweise
dran denke, sowas zu kaufen.
Das geht ja sogar.
Dass es bei der Amis geht, ist mir klar.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Die China-Chinesen.
Alles klar.
49.
Und was hält's ab?
Was hält es ab?
Weste Bulletproof.
Ob ich der China-Weste
vertrauen würde?
Ich weiß nicht.
Alles klar.
Gangster-Style.
Hahaha.
What?
Was geht mit denen ab?
Warum wird der hier angeschossen auf dem Gerüst?
Was geht...
Was ist mit den Chinesen wieder los?
Okay, es gibt keine...
Die gezeigten Bilder sind nur zur Referenz.
Ja, man sollte sich nicht ans Gerüst hängen lassen.
Das ist doch keine echte Kugelsigarette.
Das ist viel zu billig.
Das ist doch bestimmt einfach nur Faschingsverkleidung oder sowas.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das ist viel zu billig.
Sowas kostet wahrscheinlich normalerweise deutlich, deutlich vielstellig.
Okay.
Äh, was war jetzt mit Veracrypt nochmal?
Ich benutze Veracrypt.
Ja.
Äh, die Default, Default.
Was auch immer die da vorschlagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, welchen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus.
Das Default wahrscheinlich AES.
Wo man sich, also irgendwas, wo man sich keine Gedanken machen muss.
Also sowas ist bei meiner Berufsschule nicht passiert.
Also in meiner Berufsschule ist nichts, ist nichts zusammengebrochen oder sonst was.
Die war nur an sich ziemlich, ziemlich im Arsch.
Ja.
Werner von Siemens Schule Frankfurt.
Guckt euch mal an.
Ja, nur vom Feinsten hier.
Guckt mal, nur vom Feinsten.
Meine Berufsschule.
Richtig.
Hightech.
Overhead-Projektor.
Bild von 2018.
Was sonst?
Overhead-Projektor.
So, dann so super, super tolle Außenbereiche.
Das sieht aus, ich weiß nicht, wie irgendwie die Abstellkammer aus dem Knast oder so.
Aber nein, das ist die Wand von der Berufsschule.
Die ist eh generell gebaut wie ein Knast.
Das hier, das Zeug.
Was das hier sein soll, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Das ist nicht die Berufsschule.
Aha, Sporthalle.
Ja, so sah die aus.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ja, irgendwelche Matratzen.
Das ist der Eingang.
Genau, das ist der Eingang.
Und das Ding sieht wirklich genauso hässlich aus.
Also, ich meine, das ist noch ein schönes Foto von der Berufsschule.
Also, wenn das schon ein schönes Foto ist,
dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie der Rest...
Guckt mal hier, aber diese gehen mit der Zeit.
Nicht RGB-Beleuchtung, aber schon mal Fake-RGB-Beleuchtung.
Okay.
Okay, Stühle und Tische, das ist noch genau der gleiche Müll wie bei mir damals.
Dreck.
Was auch immer das sein soll.
Noch mehr Dreck.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Gutloidstraße 333 bis...
Da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, die Straße ist relativ lang, wenn es da Hausnummer 335 gibt.
Ja, so sieht das von außen aus.
Nur, eins stimmt hier nicht so.
Die Leute sehen nicht Gangster genug aus, die da...
...vorstehen.
Da ist wahrscheinlich gerade keine Pause oder sonst was.
Oh, das ist...
Es ist zu...
Ne, es ist 2009, da war ich auch da.
Moment, sieht man mich hier vielleicht?
Bin ich das?
Ne, 2000...
2009 war ich, glaub schon, gar nicht mehr da.
Ne.
Keinen, den ich kenne, so vom...
...vom Umfang her.
Ja, gut, meine Berufsschule.
Übelster, übelster Sack.
All die Musik ist mir ein bisschen hektisch jetzt.
Publik.
Hab ich doch schon.
Fast, fast.
Ja, aber ich wollte jetzt noch...
Leute, ich wollte jetzt noch mal eine...
Ne, ich glaube, ich muss nicht...
Ich wollte jetzt noch mal eine Sache sagen.
Zu dieser Geschichte mit...
...meiner Hardware geht so kaputt, ne?
Also, ich hatte doch...
Also, erstens...
Erstens eine Sache, die ich mir auf gar keinen Fall kaufen würde mehr.
Corsar-Tastaturen.
Das Ding war von Anfang an...
Moment, muss ich mal angucken, was der ganze Krempel kostet, ne?
Guckt euch mal...
...den Preis an für die Tastaturen.
Die sind doch nicht mal ganz dicht.
180 Euro für eine Tastatur.
Monarch S.
Was ist da?
Ist da irgendwie...
Gold-Einlagen oder sowas?
Was ist da drinne?
Zumindest die Tastatur...
Ich glaube, die hatte ich hier.
Die Tastatur, die ist mega...
Also...
Ist einfach Schrott.
Ich hab das Ding ausgepackt, angeschlossen.
Erstens, was mich total irritiert hat...
Und das, glaube ich, geht den meisten so...
...die so ein bisschen so Feeling...
So viel...
So, wo welche Knöpfe...
Also, die nicht immer permanent auf die Tastatur gucken.
Die so ein Feeling entwickelt haben.
Wo welche Tasten sind.
Man ist gewöhnt, dass unten links...
Unten links ist welche Taste?
Control.
Und wenn du unten links an die Tastatur kreist...
...und es ist auf einmal G6...
...irritiert das.
Gut.
Und das eigentliche Problem ist...
...dass ich doppelte Tastenanschläge hatte.
Fast von Anfang an...
...total ermüdet.
Das Ding.
So.
Aber jetzt...
Jetzt...
Das eigentliche, worauf ich raus wollte.
Ich hab...
Ich hab ja die ganze Zeit hier eine Logitech G Pro Wireless Maus.
So.
Sowas.
Sowas da.
So, die hab ich mir gekauft vor...
Ja, mit Schocks am Start.
Oui, oui.
Ähm...
So, die hab ich mir gekauft zusammen...
...mit einem Wireless Maus-Auflade-Gamepad.
Eigentlich eine ganz coole Kombination.
So.
Letztens...
Ist die...
Ist die linke Maustaste irgendwie kaputt gegangen.
Wenn ich hier geklickt habe...
Also ich drück jetzt...
Ich drück jetzt die linke Maustaste.
Dann hat es permanent markiert, anmarkiert...
Wie auch immer.
Das hat also permanent geklickt.
Wenn man die linke Maustaste nur leicht gehalten hat.
So, ich hab...
Ich hab vom Chat natürlich auch wieder...
...zig Hinweise bekommen.
So nach dem Motto...
Ich soll mal Öl reinsprayen oder was auch immer.
Hab ich alles nicht gemacht.
Ich hab mir gedacht...
Weißt du was?
Ich hab das Ding ja erst vor irgendwie eineinhalb Jahren gekauft.
Die tauschen es doch bestimmt aus.
Bin ich zu Amazon...
...in die Kaufhistorie gegangen.
Und hab gesagt...
Hier ist kaputt.
Da hat Amazon gleich schon hingeschrieben.
Ja, ja, nee.
Das ist zu lange her.
Schon über ein halbes Jahr.
Geh mal zu Logitech.
Okay.
So.
Dann bin ich zu Logitech auf die Seite gegangen.
Dann musst du dich erstmal anmelden.
Ich zeige euch...
Also ich melde mich jetzt nicht an.
Aber es ist schon hart...
...hart sinnlos.
Du musst...
Du musst dich...
Du musst dich registrieren.
Also erste Mal hier was zu finden ist schon...
...ist schon der Wahnsinn.
Mäuse und Zeiger.
Trauma.
Gaming-Mäuse.
So.
Mehr.
Wireless.
Pro.
Pro Wireless da.
So.
Dann musst...
Musst du da rein.
Dann musst du irgendwie hier auf Garantie.
Und dann musst du sagen...
Ausfüllen Garantieantrag.
Und dann musst du dich anmelden.
Und wenn du dich dann anmelden musst...
Und wenn du dich dann angemeldet hast.
Wenn du dich dann angemeldet hast...
...dann kriegst du erstmal so eine komische Auswahl...
...was du alles durchklicken musst.
Und wenn du dann sagst...
Hey, ich will trotzdem einen Support-Fall aufmachen.
Dann kommt ein Link und du kommst im Forum raus.
Und im Forum...
Keine Ahnung, in so einer Knowledge-Base.
Und in der Knowledge-Base steht...
Deine Maus muss...
Also du musst erstmal, um deine Maus zu fixen, die Logitech-Software neu installieren.
Und da habe ich mir dann gedacht...
Piss dich an.
Also.
So.
Und jetzt kommt der Punkt, auf den ich eigentlich raus will.
Ich bin dann zu Amazon...
...in die Orders rein.
Und habe Support angeklickt bei Amazon.
Dann bin ich bei irgendeiner Support-Dame gelandet von Amazon.
Die heißen immer Tina, Maria, sonst wie.
Die heißen wahrscheinlich gar nicht so in echt.
Habe ich den Support angeschrieben.
Habe das erzählt.
Und habe gesagt, hier.
Ich habe das gekauft.
Linke Maustaste hängt.
Und Logitech sagt nur, ich soll die Software neu installieren.
Kann man die nicht irgendwie replacen?
Und da hat sie gesagt, ja Moment, ich gucke mal kurz nach.
Und nach zwei Minuten sagen sie, ja, kein Problem.
Einfach zurückschicken.
Also, nee, wir schicken die neue los.
Einfach die alte zurückschicken.
Hier ist der QR-Code zum Ausdrücken.
Fertig.
Das war eine Sache von fünf Minuten.
So, und jetzt frage ich euch mal.
Warum?
Sollte ich noch woanders kaufen als Amazon?
Amazon ist sicherlich nicht der perfekte Laden.
Aber für mich als Endkunde ist es ein ziemlich guter Laden.
Man kann sich sicherlich bei Amazon drüber.
Darüber streiten, was die Arbeitsbedingungen sind und alles mögliche.
Ja, das ist keine Frage.
Aber für einen als Endkunde ist das eine super Geschichte.
Was meint ihr, warum jeder nur noch bei Amazon kauft?
Es ist doch, es ist doch, es ist doch kein Wunder.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern.
Die Geschichte.
Ich weiß, ist der Chainlord da?
Der kann jetzt wieder schreiben.
Recycle Story.
Ich kann mich noch an Dinge erinnern, wo ich mal im normalen Laden versucht habe, Hardware umzutauschen.
Das ist ein Riesenakt.
Die legen einem da so Steine, Steine in den Weg.
Ich musste mal einen Drucker.
Ich habe mal vor Ewigkeiten einen Drucker.
Also das ist so die schlimmste, die schlimmste Service Erfahrung, die ich jemals hatte.
Ich habe mal vor einer Weile ganz, ganz lange her.
Da gab es noch Phobis.
Gibt es, gibt es hier noch Phobis?
Tatsächlich Phobis gibt es noch.
Übelster Schrottladen, Alter.
Phobis.
Die Phobis Story, ja.
Einer braucht euch mehr, ist die Phobis Story.
Zum Glück.
Zumindest, ich habe meine Druckerpatrone gekauft, bei Phobis.
Das ist schon ganz lange her.
Das ist die schlimmste Service Erfahrung, die ich je hatte.
Und bin heimgekommen, die hat Schlieren gedruckt.
Ich meine, woran soll das bitteschön sonst liegen, außer, dass die Patrone kaputt ist?
Bei diesen Billigdruckern tauscht so mit der Patrone alles aus.
Köpfe.
Tinte.
Alles.
Warum sollte mein Drucker Schlieren drucken?
Mit der alten Patrone nicht und mit der neuen Patrone würde er das machen.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Also habe ich die Patrone genommen, bin wieder hingefahren zu Phobis.
Und habe gesagt, Leute, die Patrone ist kaputt.
Ich brauche eine andere.
Da habe ich gesagt, das glauben sie nicht.
Die ist nicht kaputt.
Da habe ich gesagt, wie soll ich euch das jetzt beweisen?
Ich mache mir nur die Arbeit, hin und zurück zu fahren.
Und das lief dann darauf, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ich musste dann, also sie wollten zum Umtauschen, meinen Drucker damit hinbringen.
Dass sie dann sehen, dass der Schlieren druckt.
Und waren mega unfreundlich.
Alter, ich wäre dem gerne am liebsten, damals schon, da war ich aber noch klein, mit dem
Arsch ins Gesicht gesprungen.
So.
Und bei solchen Dingern musst du dich doch nicht mehr wundern, wenn die Leute einfach
zu Amazon gehen.
Amazon hat eigentlich die beste, also vor allem gerade, dass sich da noch die Leute
im Einzelhandel beschweren, dass keiner mehr zu ihnen geht.
Ja klar, weil es bei Amazon easy as fuck ist alles.
Der einzige Vorteil, den du hast, ist, dass du es direkt bekommst, wenn du lokal in ein
Geschäft gehst.
Weil normalerweise ist es ja so, also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber bei mir
ist es so, ich überlege mir meistens eine ganze Weile, ob ich was haben will oder nicht.
Aber wenn ich mich dann dazu entschieden habe, dass ich es haben will, dann muss das schnell
gehen.
Kennt ihr das?
So nach dem Motto, soll ich mir das jetzt kaufen?
Soll ich mir einen Rechner kaufen?
Soll ich mir eine Maus kaufen?
Soll ich mir ein Fernseher kaufen?
Soll ich mir eine neue Konsole kaufen?
Ja.
Soll ich das machen?
Und wenn ich dann sage, ja, ich mache es, dann sage ich, bam, es muss jetzt, jetzt
sofort da sein.
So, und das ist der einzige Vorteil, den irgendwelche Geschäfte vor Ort haben, dass du dann schnell
hinfahren kannst und sagen, hier, gib mal her, ich habe es direkt.
Aber, aber, mittlerweile ist es so, Amazon ist so schnell und so unkompliziert bei allem
drumherum, sogar teilweise Same-Day-Delivery, dass es keinerlei Vorteile macht, im Laden
zu kaufen, außer, dass du Stress hast, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Weil Amazon macht die einzig sinnvolle Taktik, die neben dem Durchschnitt, also, was ich
damit meine ist, also, zum Beispiel Amazon Logistik.
Ich weiß nicht, wer schon mal die Ehre hat, von Amazon Logistics beliefert zu werden.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, die meisten, ja.
Amazon Logistics ist ja im Prinzip auch nur Subunternehmer, Subunternehmer des Subunternehmers,
des lokalen Subunternehmers und der Fahrer als Subunternehmer.
Also, der Fahrer kriegt am Ende 1,50 oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall ziemliches Ausbeuter-Ding, gehe ich mal ganz stark von
aus.
Aber, die Taktik bei Amazon Logistik ist folgende.
Scheiß auf Sicherheit bei Zustellung.
So nach dem Motto, DHL musst du unterschreiben, wobei, DHL unterschreiben von wegen, ja, passt
mal auf.
Von wegen DHL unterschreiben.
Letztens ist der DHL-Typ, ist er nicht niedlich.
Letztens der DHL-Typ, ich habe ein Foto gemacht von der Kamera, ich habe eine Kamera oben
mittlerweile.
Das ist, das ist der Gehweg vom Haus, da liegt einfach, da liegt, also das hier ist das Hoftor,
da liegt einfach das Paket.
Der Typ hat geklingelt, ich bin drangegangen, habe gesagt, ja, Moment, ich komme, ich komme
ans Fenster.
Und als ich am Fenster war, war der Typ im Auto und ist abgehauen.
Und das Paket lag einfach mitten auf dem Gehweg.
Ich hatte nichts an, großartig, ich konnte nicht mal raus, ich musste dann erstmal hoch,
mich anziehen, auf die Gas, also, das kann es ja nicht sein.
Zumindest Amazon macht ähnliche Taktik, aber, aber bei Amazon ist es folgendermaßen.
Das Paket ist happy, ja.
Aber bei Amazon ist es folgendermaßen.
Amazon ist happy.
Ja.
Amazon, also gehe ich ganz stark von aus, Amazon kalkuliert das anders.
Amazon macht ja standardmäßig keine Unterschrift und Amazon wirft standardmäßig auch Dinge
auf gut Glück einfach übers Hoftor, weil die denken sich, das spart uns so viel Zeit,
dass wir das alles nicht machen müssen und in den 1% der Fällen, wo es nicht funktioniert,
bezahlen wir es halt.
Stellt euch mal vor, die pfeffern was, die pfeffern mal eine neue Maus.
Ja.
Die pfeffern mal ein neues Hoftor und die geht da, geht dabei kaputt.
So, was mache ich dann?
Ich lasse mir von Amazon eine neue schicken, aber das passiert in vielleicht 1% der Fälle
und die Zeit, die die sparen mit nicht lange zustellen, ist wahrscheinlich billiger, als
dass die ab und zu mal bezahlen müssen, dass das, dass das kaputt geht und so machen die
das anscheinend auch, wenn du Sachen zurückschicken willst.
Die gucken, die gehen wahrscheinlich in dein Profil gucken.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass der Amazon Support mit einem neuen Paket, also, ich weiß nicht,
ob der Amazon Support mit dabei ist, der geht in dein Profil gucken, ob du so notorischer
Zurückschicker bist, so 8% der Dinger, dann machen sie es vielleicht nicht, aber die sehen
bei mir, der Typ, der gibt tausende, zehntausende Euro hier bei Amazon aus und schickt so gut
wie nichts zurück.
Da sind wir einfach mal nett zu dem, dass der weitere zehntausend Euro bei uns ausgibt
über die nächsten Jahre und das ist ja auch nicht dumm von Amazon, weil genau das mache
ich.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Deswegen alle, alle nur bei Amazon.
Und wie schlecht das so aussieht.
Ja.
Bei Amazon Support, wie schlecht der Support aussehen kann, habe ich letztens wieder gemerkt
bei Microsoft.
Ich habe angerufen bei Microsoft, äh, wir haben äh, äscher, äscher, äscher Probleme
gehabt.
Ähm, ja, hier, wir haben angerufen bei, also ich habe, ich habe angerufen beim Azure Support.
Leute, das könnt ihr komplett vergessen, ich hatte irgendeinen Inder dran, der hieß irgendwie
Gang, Gangkarn Dieb oder so, ich kann den Namen mir schon gar nicht mehr merken.
Warte mal.
Der Name, Name Gang, nee, Gang, nee, nicht, nee, äh, ach, keine Ahnung, ähnliche Namen.
Nicht Gandhi, ja.
Zumindest, er hat null gecheckt, ich habe es 50 mal erzählt, äh, äh, es war zumindest
komplett, äh, komplett sinn, sinnlos.
Es geht immer noch um die gleiche Geschichte, die ich euch letztens erzählt habe, dass,
äh, File-Geschichten in Azure so langsam sind.
Ja.
Und im Prinzip kriegst du von Microsoft Support als Antwort immer nur das, was du eh schon
ins Ticket geschrieben hast, nochmal hinten drauf.
So, und der Hit kam dann zumindest am Ende, da meinte er zu mir so, also es hat sich null,
es hat überhaupt nichts gebracht, er hat im Prinzip einfach die gleiche Sache erzählt
nochmal, die schon im Ticket drin stand und, äh, ich, ich meine, gut, äh, das bringt
jetzt, bringt jetzt nicht viel und dann meinte er am Ende zu mir so noch so, thank you for
call.
No need to worry.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, ja, alles klar, okay, ich muss jetzt nochmal irgendeinen anrufen,
der Ahnung hat.
Das, also das war, das war halt Kack-Support.
Microsoft ist aber auch Spezialist drin, sinnlose Support-Antworten zu geben.
Ihr müsst euch mal die offiziellen Support-An, äh, Antworten angucken von irgendwelchen Tickets,
also nicht von, von Tickets von, äh, so Hilfe, Hilfe-Anfragen aus diesem Microsoft-Support-Forum,
die sind so unsinnig, schwachsinnig, wie die immer beantwortet werden, aber das ist, aber
das ist nicht nur...
Das ist nicht nur da.
Eines der bescheuertsten Support-Support-Sachen, die ich im Internet letztens gesehen habe,
ist folgendes, warte mal, WhatsApp Video Call Locked iPhone, mal gucken, ob ich das
nochmal finde.
Hier, ah, das ist, das ist auch geil.
Das ist hier, das ist, das ist hier der Apple Community Spezialist, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob, ob, ob da wirklich einer von Apple ist, aber das ist auch so eine, das ist eine typische
Support-Anfrage.
Wie, wie, wie, wie sie eigentlich funktioniert.
Ja.
Das ist einfach sinnlos beantwortet, also der Typ fragt hier, wie kann ich einen WhatsApp
Video Call annehmen, wenn mein, also vom Lockscreen die Antwort ist, das geht nicht.
Du kannst den Call annehmen, musst aber anlocken für Video-Funktionalität.
Das ist, das ist die korrekte Antwort, aber guckt euch mal an, wie bescheuert die Support-Antwort
ist.
Welcome.
I understand from your question that you want to answer calls from your lock screen for
WhatsApp.
Das ist, das ist Schwachsinn, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Er will nicht, er will nicht Calls annehmen, er will Video-Calls vom Lockscreen annehmen,
das ist was komplett anderes.
Das ist so, das ist so eine typische Text-Block-Schwachsinn-Support-Message, die du mittlerweile am laufenden Band bekommst,
sei es bei Microsoft oder hier in dem Fall, sei es bei Apple, sei es bei Google, sei es
bei, was weiß ich, bei allen möglichen, so diese, diese Textbox-Antworten, die absolut
keinen Sinn ergibt.
Das ist nicht das, was er gefragt hat.
Er hat gefragt Video-Calls und Video-Calls sind was komplett anderes, als Calls annehmen
vom Lockscreen.
Totaler Schwachsinn.
Ja, weil ich hab letztens auch danach gesucht und hab diese Support-Message gefunden, deswegen
ist mir das hier gerade aufgefallen.
So.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer Sunrise ist, wer ist denn Sunrise?
Sunrise Communications, ah, das ist, ah, Schweiz, Schweiz, äh, Internet-Stelz, ja, ja gut, Microsoft,
das hieß ja schon an Windows 11.
Ja, das kann sein, das kann sein, dass der irgendwie so einen ähnlichen Namen hat, ja.
Ähm, Microsoft, das hieß ja schon an Windows 11, das ist irgendwie total unsinnig alles.
Was sagst du zur Azure- und der Omni-God-Lücke?
Äh, gar nichts, was soll ich da großartig zu sagen?
Das ist viel, viel schlimmer aufgebauscht, als es eigentlich ist.
Also das hier ist irgendein Management-Service von, äh, von Microsoft, die, der standardmäßig
auf Azure-4Ms vorinstalliert wird.
Ja.
Und darüber kann man relativ trivial, wenn das ansprechbar ist, äh, ja, Lücken ausnutzen.
Das Problem ist nur, was bei den meisten Artikeln darüber vergessen wird, dass nichts davon
im Internet hängt standardmäßig.
Du kommst überhaupt nicht von außen da dran.
Also, ja, die Lücke an sich ist, ist, ist mal wieder, äh, lull, aber es, es hat kaum
Auswirkungen.
Benutzt Veracrypt in einer hardwaregebunden Key oder wie verhält sich das, wenn man die
Platte in einem anderen PC tut?
Ähm.
Ja.
Wenn du die Platte in einen anderen PC tust, äh, und von der Platte bootest, musst du ganz
normal das Passwort eingeben.
Ne, ne, das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert.
Also Veracrypt macht das folgendermaßen, wie das funktioniert.
Ich zeig mal so.
Für alle, die keinen Bock haben, BitLocker oder irgendein Microsoft-Zeug zu verwenden
können, Veracrypt verwenden.
Übrigens die einzige Software aus Frankreich, was ist das für Musik, oh, das ist Splatoon
oder sowas.
Ähm.
Wer keinen Bock hat, äh, BitLocker oder sowas zu verwenden, kann Veracrypt verwenden.
Das ist quasi das, was früher TrueCrypt war.
Ja.
Plus, äh, Baguette.
Kannste Festplatten vollverschlüsseln.
Also.
Wie die das machen, ist folgendermaßen.
Wenn man Veracrypt startet und seine Festplatte vollverschlüsselt, dann funktioniert das
folgendermaßen.
Die installieren erstmal einen eigenen Bootloader.
In diesem Bootloader muss man dann ein Passwort eingeben zur Festplatte entsperren beim Booten.
Aber.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht etwa so, dass eure Festplatte mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt
ist.
Warum ist das nicht?
Veracrypt generiert, Veracrypt ist doch auch unsicher, nö, warum sollte das unsicher sein?
Veracrypt generiert beim, äh, Setup-Vorgang für die Festplatte, generiert das geheime,
ziemlich langen geheimen Schlüssel, der wird am Anfang der Platte geschrieben und am Ende
der Platte geschrieben.
Warum?
Falls die Platte mal beschädigt ist, kann ich immer noch den Key auslesen, weil er zweimal
auf der Platte steht.
Dieser Key wird verschlüsselt mit eurem Passwort.
Also sprich, was ihr, was eigentlich passiert ist beim Booten, ihr gebt beim Booten euer Passwort
ein, das mit dem Passwort entschlüsselt ihr den Key auf der Platte und der Key entschlüsselt
die restliche Platte.
Warum sollte man keinen BitLocker verwenden?
Ja, vielleicht traut man Microsoft nicht.
Übrigens danke für die Subs, Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ich bin eine Hälfte
übersehen.
Tronax, danke, 11 Monate, Leko ist auch wieder am Start, unik, 9 Monate, Leko hat 12 Monate,
Hypersubscription.
Nice.
THX.
GG Eats.
Dumme Frage, was bringt BitLocker, wenn man mit Windows Login umgehen kann?
Das bringt an der Stelle gar nichts.
Wichtig ist, dass die Platte verschlüsselt ist und du ohne Passwort gar nicht an die
Platte drankommst.
Also so, wenn dein System bootet ohne Passwort bis zu Windows Login, dann ist es unsinnig.
Du brauchst beim, du brauchst beim Booten, also bevor die Festplatte überhaupt zugreifbar
ist, da musst du ein Passwort eingeben.
Ansonsten ist es sinnlos.
Ich weiß nicht, ob VeraSecureBoot, äh, VeraCryptSecureBoot geht, keine Ahnung.
Dazu brauch ich SecureBoot.
Freust du dich auf Battlefield 2042?
Ja.
Es wurde ja verschoben, aber wie gesagt, das hab ich ja, hab ich ja schon prophezeit, dass
das wahrscheinlich so sein wird.
Hatte ich mal wieder recht, bei 80% der Sachen, wo ich nicht recht habe, erwähne ich jetzt
halt einfach nicht.
So, was, was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an?
Wo wir, wo wir es gerade von Amazon hatten.
Ich hatte doch irgendein Video hier.
Was mir vorgeschlagen wurde.
Why I quit Amazon.
Amazon.
Software Engineer.
Weiß nicht, warum mir das vorgeschlagen wird, aber jetzt können wir uns mal anhören, was
er sagt.
Why I quit.
Welcome to Pirate King.
I'm Daniel.
Bisschen leise, hä?
Ex-Software Engineer at Amazon.
Bisschen sehr leise.
Also, a software engineering mentor at two educational startups.
In this video, I'm going to talk about the reason why I quit.
Welcome to Pirate King.
Ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin der Ex-Software Engineer at Amazon.
Ich bin auch ein Software-Engineer und Mentor bei zwei educational Startups.
In this video, I'm going to talk about the reasons.
Welcome to Pirate King.
Die Audio-Quali ist richtig mies.
Ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin ein Software-Engineer bei Microsoft.
Ex-Software Engineer bei Amazon und Ebay.
Und auch ein Software-Engineer und Mentor bei zwei educational Startups.
In this video, ich werde...
Mist, was war jetzt mit BitLocker und Ferrakrypt?
Wie, was soll da jetzt gewesen sein?
Ich hoffe, jetzt ist es laut genug.
Wow, Alter, ist ja gut.
Bonk, HS.
Tronax, sag ich schon.
10 Subscriptions.
Stell so, 19 Monate.
Nochmal Hyper-Subscriben.
Ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin der Ex-Software Engineer bei Microsoft.
Ex-Software Engineer bei Amazon.
Bonk, HS.
Also, a software engineering mentor at two educational startups.
Tronax, sag ich schon.
10 Subscriptions.
Stell so, 19 Monate.
Nochmal Hyper-Subscriben.
Danke, danke, Leute.
Zeig mal her.
Wer hat ein Glück gehabt?
Lunn.
Eins, zwei.
Ne.
Zwei, fünf, sechs, acht.
Serio.
Denkpepp.
Piep.
Jockelbar.
Nils B.
Bremer.
Xenom.
Life.
Ofenkartoffel.
Ltd.
Basti.
Andi X.
TV.
Und Crysis.
Ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin der Ex-Software Engineer bei Microsoft.
Ich bin Bibi Xenom.
Und es ist 666.
Jawoll.
Wer hat gedodged?
Älfris Chat hat wieder, hat gedodged.
Nice.
Okay, was sagt er denn?
Moin.
JVP.
Nimmst du Chromium?
Ja.
Warum nicht.
Ich habe alles Mögliche in Sinn.
So.
Also, warum hat er gequittet bei Amazon?
Also ich muss sagen, die Beleuchtung und der Sound ist vielleicht nicht die beste vom Video.
Aber er ist ja auch Software Entwickler.
Musste es nicht können.
Sei sicher, dass du bis zum Ende bleibst, wenn du dich darüber interessierst.
Und in dieser Zeit werde ich es noch einmal machen.
In einem Q&A Format, ich hoffe ihr genießt es.
Okay.
Also, fangen wir mit der ersten Frage an.
Wie lange arbeitete ich bei Amazon?
Ich arbeitete bei Amazon für etwa 13 Monate.
Also habe ich angefangen, für Amazon zu arbeiten.
Das ist gebrochen, af.
Wie hast du dein TTS für dein Meme Board gemacht?
Du meinst das hier?
Du meinst sowas hier?
Fick dich weg du Robo-Förster.
Nee, ach Quatsch.
Du meinst das hier, oder?
Das ist ein koreanischer Text-to-Speech-Service.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Okay.
Also jetzt sind wir aber auch noch ein Jahr da.
Die haben alle keinen Bock darauf.
Okay.
Also jetzt sind wir aber auch noch ein Jahr da.
Die haben alle keinen Bock darauf.
Und wie es vorhin gesagt wurde,
habe ich mich Cordial überlegt, Amazon zu verlassen.
Vor 3 Monaten, nachdem ich da war.
Und?
HÄ??
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Er hatte nach 3 Monaten keinen Bock mehr und war dann 13 Monate da.
Hi-Fet move.
Na gut, vielleicht hatte er ja seine Gründe dafür.
Ja, ähm, viele Faktoren.
Die Kompensation war für mich keine wirkliche große Herausforderung.
Aber ich denke ich wusste, dass ich da bleiben würde,
wenn ich nicht so glücklich wäre.
Ja, und mit den reichen Bedienungen der Unternehmen
und der oppressiven Kultur der Unternehmen,
bei uns haben arbeitgeber in deutschland allgemein keine benefits oder selten
selten und zumindest nicht in dem ausmaß wie das in den usa teilweise gang und
gäbe ist also wenn ich hier hier hast du glück wenn sie sich beteiligen an deiner
monats fahrkarte oder sowas
alter alter welcher sofort dabei stell dir mal vor ihr kriegt komplett
verpflegung essen umsonst von einem arbeitgeber
wir haben eine eigene kantine da ist wirklich eigen ist sie nicht wir haben
eine kantine wo wir ein bisschen günstiger essen bekommen das alles jawohl
lehrt der art to major companies in the u.s. that still do not provide free food
to the employees amazon in microsoft okay gut
fml and i'm not a thing that was critical in my decision was amazon screen card
sponsorship so i think they change die korke das ist ein meeting sponsor green
cards for all software engineers now but it wasn't incorporated during my
employment and being a restraint to work and living as a foreigner really such a
work and living as a foreigner really such a work and living as a foreigner really such a
aqua kom aí dan hygiene oder wo kommt dann wird kommt er denn hier ist es komm
jetzt hat koreaner oder weiß nicht ob er das sagt oder ob er das schon gesagt hat
ist Qualität
Training
Okay okay wenn er als ausländer in kanada südkorea japan lebt dann kann er
schon mal nicht japaner oder südkoreaner sein also was istannah china chinese call of duty
was ist fine
Ahnung, er könnte ja alles mögliche aus der Ecke sein, weiß man nicht.
And I already knew that other companies sponsor permanent resident cards, but why
not Amazon? So, you know, another compelling reason. Vietnam? Lastly, as I've
mentioned in my previous videos, Amazon doesn't really have comparable
benefits. They give you free Starbucks coffee, $100 to spend on Amazon.com per
year. Oh, das ist aber großzügig von Amazon, 100 Euro Gutschein im Jahr. Gut,
natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen, sie müssten es auch gar nicht machen.
Aber, also, naja, vielleicht ist es nicht so viel.
Ja, that's literally it. Nothing else. It made its impact to the local
community, though. It killed the local banana market because nobody was
buying bananas from the grocery stores anymore.
Na gut.
I'll say that it's really competitive. I honestly can't say most of my
co-workers were actually co-workers. Everyone kind of felt like they were
my competitors.
Das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Performance Improvement Plan. Allein schon, wisst ihr, was ich geil finde? Das ist ja
auch eine Sache, das hat sich so die letzten Jahre, Jahrzehnte über
eingeschlichen, dass man Dinger nicht mehr so nennt, wie sie eigentlich sind,
sondern das so umschreibt. Performance Improvement Plan heißt auf gut Deutsch,
du sagst, eigentlich haben wir keinen Bock.
mehr auf dich, aber vielleicht, vielleicht können wir noch irgendwas,
irgendwas machen, ja, so nach dem Motto, wenn du dich jetzt, wenn du jetzt ganz
besonders stark dich anstrengst und no-lives und alles gibst für die Firma,
dann hast du vielleicht noch eine Chance. Also im Prinzip ist, umschreibt das
eigentlich nur so nach dem Motto, eigentlich haben wir keinen Bock mehr auf
dich. So nach dem Motto, willst du, willst du nicht woanders hin oder was auch
immer. Aber jetzt ist es Performance Improvement Plan. Klingt, klingt nicht so
schlimm. Ist genauso, ist genauso ein Ding wie PTSD. Ist auch was, was komplett
komplett harmlos klingt mittlerweile. Ich meine, wer stellt sich denn ernsthaft,
wenn er das das erste Mal hört, was Schlimmes unter einer posttraumanischen
Belastungsstörung vor? Die meisten Leute können sich, glaube ich, gar nicht
ausmalen, was das, was das für betroffene Leute bedeutet. Hört sich auch gar nicht
so schlimm an. Vor allem, wenn es dann noch mit PTSD abkürzt, dann hört sich das ja
noch mal, noch weniger schlimm an. Wisst ihr, wie man das im Ersten Weltkrieg
genannt hat? Damals hat man gesagt, Shellshock dazu. Das, man ging damals von
aus, dass die, dass das durch irgendwie Druckwellen, dass die, dass das durch
Druckwellen von Geschossen und so ausgelöst wird, was ja nicht stimmt. Aber
hat man sich damals gesagt, das klingt nach richtig Impact und richtig gefährlich.
So, und das wurde jetzt über die Jahre immer weiter verwässert, bis wir
mittlerweile bei posttraumatischer Belastungsstörung rausgekommen sind, wo
sich keiner irgendwas Schlimmes mehr darunter denkt, was natürlich immer noch
für die Betroffenen genauso schlimm ist wie vorher. Also, das haben wir die
letzten Jahre wirklich perfektioniert. Du darfst ja auch nicht mal sagen, zu
irgendeinem Alter bist du dumm. Du darfst ja auch nicht mal sagen, du bist so
dumm. Das ist ja auch, das ist ja auch ganz, ganz gefährlich. Ja, es geht nicht.
Das musst du dann, musst du dann wahrscheinlich, äh, umschreiben irgendwie
anders. Okay, guck mal, weiter.
Das würde ich mir eher in China vorstellen.
Wenn Leute ohne irgendwelche Wörter einfach verschwinden.
Oh, das, aber, aber, Moment, Moment, das muss ich jetzt noch mal, Moment, Moment, Moment, was, was, was, was?
Manager getting demoted? Okay, das ist was, das fände ich, das könnten wir uns von Amazon
abgucken. Manager, die sacken, werden einfach ent-, was ist denn das Gegenteil von befördert?
Haben wir da überhaupt, degradiert heißt es, glaube ich, auf Deutsch, ne? Das, das könnten wir
eigentlich auch machen.
Manager, da, Manager, die sacken, werden wieder degradiert zu, wo sie weniger
Probleme anrichten können.
Das finde ich, ist eigentlich eine sehr sinnvolle Maßnahme.
Okay, and there's all happened within the 13 months while I worked at Amazon.
a compelling reason why I shouldn't staying, you know, get the hell out of here
as fast as possible.
No.
Okay.
Nobody would.
Ja, das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Also man kann nicht von den Leuten erwarten,
dass sie kreative Arbeiten verrichten,
wenn sie permanent Angst haben vor irgendwas.
Das kann man Stonks Leuten eigentlich nicht oft genug sagen.
Also egal was es ist, Angst oder zu viel Druck,
der ausgeübt wird, irgendwelche Sachen,
um den Leuten das Leben schwer zu machen,
das führt in der Regel nie dazu,
dass es in kreativen Berufen bessere Ergebnisse gibt.
Funktioniert nicht.
Das habe ich auch schon total oft in den Videos gesagt,
aber das klappt einfach nicht.
IT ist kreativ, natürlich.
Also wenn du gerade deinen ersten Tag auf Amazon begonnen hast,
dann bist du natürlich auf 100.000 aus 100.000 Amazonianern.
Also an meinem letzten Tag auf Amazon,
13 Monate nachdem ich dafür gearbeitet habe,
bin ich zurückgekommen auf dieses Website,
um zu sehen, wie das ist in Bezug auf Ranking.
Ist das jetzt irgendein Ding, wo dann dein Geld von abhängig ist?
Oder nee, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe,
ist das einfach nur eine Seite, wo du intern halt eben sehen kannst,
wie lange du dabei bist und sowas.
Und zu meiner Überraschung,
habe ich mich irgendwo in der Mitte befasst.
Ich glaube, es war ein bisschen über der Mitte.
Das siehst du mal, der Typ ist ein Jahr bei Amazon,
ist bei der Hälfte schon angelangt, der Beschäftigten,
also wie lange die dabei sind.
Dann kommt das ja ungefähr hin, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
oder was ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen habe,
dass die eine extrem hohe Fluktuation haben,
also sogar noch höher als die ganzen anderen Technik-Giants,
Dinger da aus den USA.
Gerade bei Microsoft ist es ja wohl mittlerweile so,
dass sie nicht nur händeringend Mitarbeiter suchen,
also man weiß ja nur, was man drüber liest,
nicht nur händeringend Mitarbeiter suchen, die Ahnung haben,
sondern dass sie auch versuchen, aktiv wirklich aktive Mitarbeiter zu halten.
Amazon denkt sich aber, brauchen wir nicht.
Es ist schon ein Jahr her, seit ich bei Amazon eingeladen bin
und ich war bereits bei dem 50. Prozentil in der Liste.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, dass Geld und Kompetenz
nicht wirklich die wichtigste Sache für mich sind.
Ich bin nicht alleine in diesem Sinne.
Also Gehalt ist natürlich wichtig.
Ich würde mal sagen, Gehalt ist natürlich schon erst mal der wichtigste Faktor,
der zum größten Teil mit entscheidet, wo man hingeht oder nicht.
Aber es ist nicht das einzig Wichtige.
Ja, ich habe bereits genug über Kultur gesprochen.
So wie der Name der Firma sagt.
Es ist wirklich eine Dschungel, in der du überleben musst.
Das hat er schon gesagt.
Wiederum, vergesst mich nicht.
Amazon ist eine tolle Firma.
Sie sind ein Fan.
Sie bezahlen Software-Ingenieure gut.
Ihre Stoffe haben sich über die letzten wenigen Jahre substanziell erhöht.
Und ich habe viele Sachen erwähnt, die ich nicht erwähnt habe,
dass sie dir kostenlose Bananen geben.
Und trotz all der Dinge, für die Amazon notoriös ist,
denke ich immer noch, dass es eine tolle Firma ist,
ein tolles Geschäft und ein tolles Ort ist, wo du arbeitest.
Aber wie bedeutet das wirklich?
Gerade als Einstieg.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele eben zu Amazon auch als Einstieg gehen
und dann feststellen Alter ist das Kacke und da wieder abhauen.
Aber ja, also insgesamt könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass tatsächlich keine schlechte erste Station ist,
bei Amazon gewesen zu sein.
Das ist halt ein Luxus, sehe ich ganz genauso wie er.
Das ist aber halt ein Luxus, den sich leider viele Leute nicht aussuchen können.
Er hat jetzt gesagt, so nach dem Motto, was bringt es ihm,
wenn das irgendwie eine super tolle Firma ist,
wenn er dann nicht glücklich ist, was macht er dann noch?
Ja, gebe ich ihm voll und ganz recht.
Ich könnte mir das auch nicht vorstellen, irgendwo zu arbeiten,
wo ich jeden Morgen kotzen muss, wenn ich auf die Arbeit fahren muss.
Leider haben diesen Luxus nicht so viele.
Es gibt genug, die müssen ein Thema machen,
die müssen ein Thema machen, die müssen ein Thema machen,
es gibt genug, die müssen täglich zur Arbeit und die hassen ihren Job.
I honestly don't think that it's fair for me to say that I was unhappy at Amazon.
I was simply unhappy at my team.
The work wasn't fun.
Not only that, I didn't think the team would help me grow into a better software engineer,
which is another factor that I was really afraid of.
Sorry, ich muss schon wieder Pause machen,
aber das ist was, das würde ich generell nicht von meiner Arbeit erwarten.
Bei den Amis ist es vielleicht anders,
aber ich muss, ich sag jetzt mal so, wie es ist.
Die Dinger, die ich auf der Arbeit mache, sorgen nicht unbedingt dafür,
dass ich wirklich mehr lerne.
Ich krieg vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Praxiserfahrung
oder ein bisschen mehr Routine in manchen Sachen,
aber wirklich Know-How aufbauen und wirklich tiefgreifend neue Sachen lernen,
machst du eigentlich so gut wie nie auf der Arbeit.
Die meisten, also 99% der Sachen, die ich gelernt habe,
sind, weil ich mich privat dafür interessiere.
Ja, I think a mix of unsatisfying work plus a lack of growth,
with a little more emphasis on the former,
is what made me decide to leave Amazon.
Nach drei Monaten.
So, the division was Amazon Prime.
The team was called CMX, Content Management Experience.
We were responsible for building platforms that marketers use
to conduct experiments like A-B testing.
And my team was responsible for building the front end of it.
Ih, front end.
I don't enjoy working in the front end.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Es muss halt sein.
Wobei, ich muss sagen,
doch, doch.
Also, front end macht schon in gewisser Weise Spaß,
wenn man sieht, dass im Browser sich was tut.
Ja, ich kann nicht sagen, dass mir das gar keinen Spaß macht.
Was mir definitiv keinen Spaß macht, sind CSS Design Geschichten.
Das liegt aber auch mit daran, dass ich da einfach zu schlecht drinne bin.
It's not that I don't enjoy front end,
but I don't like writing my own HTML in CSS.
It wouldn't have been an issue,
if I was given the HTML in CSS
and I only have, like, code on top of it.
But the thing about this platform and my team
is that it's not customer facing.
It's an internal tool used by in-company marketers.
So software engineers were really responsible
for writing their own HTML in CSS,
which really sucks.
Ich muss euch was Lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen.
Wir hatten letztens richtig, richtig krasse Probleme,
weil jemand wieder sehr verbesserungswürdig seinen Job gemacht hat.
Und zwar, es gab ein neues Update.
Also es ist ja bei uns so,
wir haben ja relativ viele Leute im Außendienst
und die kriegen Software von uns zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht so sehr im Detail beschreiben,
aber zumindest, es gab ein Update oder mehrere Updates
für die Software, die eben der Außendienst verwendet.
Und man kam auf die glorreiche Idee,
man könnte ja eine neue Java-Version verwenden.
Das Problem dabei ist, wenn du eine neue Java-Version verwendest,
musst du erstmal eine neue Runtime runterladen
und jegliche Abhängigkeiten an Libraries und sonstige Sachen,
die du verwendest, werden quasi neu kompiliert
gegen die neue Java-Version.
Das heißt, das Update war nicht wie sonst irgendwie 15 MB groß,
sondern irgendwie 500 MB groß.
Obwohl sich technisch gar nicht so viel geändert hat.
Das Problem war nur, dass die Leute Montagmorgen,
als die angefangen haben zu arbeiten,
haben die natürlich alle erstmal,
also sprich irgendwelche Außendienstleute,
haben gesagt, ich fahre jetzt irgendwo hin,
verkaufe irgendwelchen Leuten was
oder ich gucke mal meine Verträge an.
Und die haben halt ihr Außendienstsystem aufgemacht
und mussten Updates installieren.
So, und da haben dann erstmal 1000 Leute
gleichzeitig versucht, 500 MB Updates runterzuladen bei uns.
Und das war halt ein bisschen zu viel für unsere Internet-Anbindung.
Da war dann halt RIP.
Ja, aber wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Typische Entscheidung bei uns ist ja,
erstmal Panik.
Wir haben zwar mittlerweile für alles irgendwelche Workflows,
aber wenn es dann doch soweit ist, dass was kaputt geht,
dann trotzdem alle Panik.
Und scheißen auf Workflows.
Und dann haben sie zig Dinger sich überlegt,
was man machen könnte.
Und was ich witzig fand,
dass sie dann auch auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind,
eine Sache, die wir bzw. ich auch schon seit,
keine Ahnung, drei Jahren oder so erzähle,
so nach dem Motto,
warum lassen wir unsere Software-Updates
nicht einfach beispielsweise aus Azure
oder Cloudflare oder irgendwo anders ausliefern.
Das wäre ja eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Könnten wir eigentlich machen.
Wollte man bisher aber nie.
Hatten wir immer gesagt,
ah nee, das geht nicht, weil bla und so.
Naja, zumindest hatte man das Problem.
So, und dann haben sie Panik im Kreis gelaufen
und haben sich überlegt, was wir machen sollen.
So nach dem Motto,
können wir jetzt nicht doch doch schnell irgendwie
eine VM hinstellen, irgendwie sonstwie oder sonstwo.
Und dann kam die Idee,
Leute, das funktioniert alles nicht.
Zumal derjenige, der weiß,
wie das Update funktioniert, auch im Urlaub ist,
obwohl wir ja keinerlei Kopfwissen mehr haben
bei einzelnen Personen.
Und dann kam richtig
Big-Brain-Management-Entscheidung.
Wir sitzen es einfach aus.
Also hatten wir irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
drei, vier Tage permanent Fehler
und unsere Hotline,
also unsere Support-Hotline,
ist glaube ich komplett durchgedreht,
weil die drei Tage lang durchgängig bombardiert wurden
mit Leuten, die sich beschwert haben.
Die haben einfach entschieden,
wir sitzen es einfach aus, easy.
Okay, guck mal, fertig.
Ich will nicht mit den Visual Design-Ideen beschäftigt werden.
Ich kann euch eine Anekdote erzählen.
Es gab einen Fall, da habe ich eine Code-Review geliefert.
Und ein easternischer Reviewer hat mir
mit einer diensten Gesichtssache gesagt,
warum ist das Farbe grün?
Warum nicht?
Meine Antwort war eigentlich,
warum nicht?
Vielleicht hätte ich ein gutes Beispiel für rot,
orange oder blau fragen können,
oder irgendeine andere Farbe?
Aber natürlich habe ich das nicht getan.
Auf devortem habe ich mich gefragt,
was ist eure Lieblingsfarbe?
Genau, ich mache es einfach in eine andere Farbe.
Aber es ist mir doch egal.
Das stimmt.
Ja, da hat er
voll und ganz recht. Das ist
wirklich was, das kann ich so auch bei uns
hier in der Arbeitswelt, das kann ich komplett unterschreiben.
Wenn ihr einen guten Chef habt oder
einen guten Manager oder wie auch immer man das nennt
und ihr sagt dem entweder
irgendwas, was euch
persönlich nicht schmeckt,
ja, was weiß ich,
dass ihr irgendwie Probleme habt mit manchen Leuten
zusammenarbeiten, weil sowieso oder
ihr sagt vielleicht was Objektives, was nicht gut läuft.
Es reicht,
es muss, also es sollte reichen,
wenn ihr das einmal
sagt. Das heißt nicht,
dass es dann automatisch
passiert, aber
zumindest, zumindest sollte
er sich bei euch melden, ohne
dass ihr fünfmal nachfragen müsst.
Also egal, was ihr ihm sagt, es sollte dann, was weiß ich,
zwei, drei Wochen dauern oder
wenn es was Komplizierteres ist,
meinetwegen auch länger, dann sollte er euch
sagen, was rausgekommen ist oder zwischendurch so hier,
ich habe das jetzt da und da weitergegeben,
ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was da rauskommt,
aber ich habe auf jeden Fall was
gemacht. Also das, das ist wichtig,
das ist das, was bei uns teilweise
funktioniert, also bei meinem Chef klappt das eigentlich
ganz gut, wenn man da was sagt
oder auch umgedreht, deswegen
versuche ich mich dann auch immer schnell um die Sachen zu kümmern,
wenn er was sagt,
aber auf anderen Ebenen klappt
das bei uns überhaupt nicht.
Ich weiß,
wir hatten zum Beispiel,
ein Kollege von mir,
der im anderen Team ist, da auf der Arbeit,
der hatte einen Chef, das war so der typische
Vertreter von, ja, da sind wir
dran. Kennt ihr so diese Antwort?
So nach dem Motto,
hier, wir haben festgestellt, das Passwort
für unsere Testumgebung
ist zu einfach, das muss geändert werden.
Ja, da sind wir dran.
Da sind wir dran.
Da sind wir dran. Da fragst du ein halbes Jahr später,
und wie sieht es aus? Ah, da sind wir dran.
Ah, da sind wir dran.
Mitgenommen, da sind wir dran.
Es ist in Klärung, genau, es ist in Klärung.
Also, davon gibt es
viel zu viele, die diese
Taktik fahren. Das stimmt, aber das ist
wirklich so, es ist genauso, es ist
wirklich sagt,
genauso wie er sagt, wenn ihr
einen guten Chef oder einen guten Manager habt,
oder auch, kann man übertragen, guten
Projektleiter oder was auch immer, Teamleiter,
wie auch immer,
das muss reichen, wenn ihr
auf ein Problem hinweist,
und dann tut sich was.
Es heißt nicht, dass es automatisch so gemacht
wird, wie ihr das sagt, aber sollte sich was
tun, und ihr solltet davon erfahren, was
rausgekommen ist. Ja, da hat
er voll und ganz recht.
A.k.a. it's time for you to leave.
So I brought it up to my manager and
explicitly told him that I want to work more on
back-end and not front-end.
I mean, I'm a...
Sorry, ich muss laufen und unterbrechen, aber ich kann
mich da echt gut mit identifizieren.
Zum Beispiel, wo man das sieht,
ich hab bei meinem Chef seit
einer ganzen Weile schon erzählt,
hier, ich würde gerne ein bisschen mehr
Zeug programmieren,
wieder, wieder ein bisschen mehr
selbst Zeug programmieren, und das klappt jetzt
auch, hat eine Weile gedauert, ja,
aber das funktioniert jetzt auch, ich kann jetzt
wieder ein bisschen mehr Zeug basteln,
wo ich ja schon die ganze Zeit scharf drauf war,
weil immer nur Code-Reviewen ist auch
doof.
Und das hat jetzt auch
funktioniert, ja, wir haben jetzt einige Tools
am Start, die es so nicht gegeben hätte,
wenn ich die nicht gebaut hätte.
Und die hat keiner in dem Sinn,
dass man irgendwie extern beauftragt
meist, ja, also das, das funktioniert schon.
Wenn man, wenn man an beiden Stellen Personen hat,
die, die das wollen.
...Engineer, right?
Amazon is actually a little special in that sense,
that the roles are explicitly separated.
Front-end engineers, as the name suggests,
only work on the front-end, and software engineers,
well, work on a mix of both, or just the back-end.
Anyways, I did tell him my true feelings and asked him
whether a change would be possible, and I remember him
saying yes, but with a very reluctant...
Okay, er muss yes sagen, hat aber keinen Bock.
...best, but that best didn't really sound like the best to me.
You know, if he did really try his best, then he would have at least,
like, come to me and say something like,
I did my best, but I wasn't able to find any back-end work for you now.
It would be okay for you to wait a little until I find it.
Genau, man braucht, man braucht, man braucht einfach Rückmeldung,
man muss einfach wissen, was Sache ist.
Hab ich euch mal die Story erzählt, wie lang das gedauert hat?
Ich glaube, das habe ich, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das, doch, habe ich bestimmt schon gemacht.
Wie lang das gedauert hat damals, als ich Teilzeitarbeiten beantragt habe bei uns?
Es war der typische Fall von, mein damaliger Chef hat es verkackt,
aber richtig mega verschissen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das erzählt habe.
Es war, es hat ewig gedauert, es hat wirklich ewig gedauert.
Und man hat nie was gehört, die ganze Zeit nicht.
Ich musste ja dann sogar, ich musste ja sogar zum Betriebsrat, ja,
das hat ewig gedauert.
Ich war aber halt auch einer der Ersten, der das gemacht hat.
Aber, warum ist er dann 13 Monate dabei geblieben?
Wenn er nach drei Monaten keinen Bock hat.
Hier ist das Ding, bei Amazon, wenn du Teams verändern willst,
musst du immer noch die vollen On-Site-Coding-Interviews durchgehen,
um das zu machen.
Das bedeutet einen Monat von Leak-Coding, viele Präparationen.
Also, wenn du dir das vorstellst.
Was ist das?
Was ist denn Leak-Coding?
Ist das so eine Übungsseite?
Stocks!
Was ist, okay, das ist so ein Ami-Ding.
Was ist RSU?
Ist das sowas, was du von deinem Gehalt in Aktien bekommst?
Was hast du da?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist.
ot
§
p.
Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Warum ist er noch so lange dabei geblieben?
Also ist er doch Südkoreaner?
Ich glaube, er ist noch so lange dabei geblieben, dass er noch so lange dabei geblieben ist, dass er noch so lange dabei geblieben ist.
Ja, ich meine, bei seinen 5% hättest du es wahrscheinlich nicht gebracht.
Das kann ich alles nachvollziehen. Klingt echt nach Hand und Fuß, was er erzählt hat, ja.
Ey, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Muss ich nicht wissen, ich werde mich wahrscheinlich nie beim Microsoft bewerben.
Ich würde Chat gucken, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Keine Ahnung, ich finde, das wäre auch teilweise echt bei uns in Deutschland auch eine coole Option.
Ich glaube, die meisten machen das hier nicht.
Ne.
Ich würde sagen, wir lassen uns jetzt mal eine Runde von LevelCapture baden.
Neues Battlefield 20, sondern die Beta-Date liegt.
Ja, nachdem sie den Kram, ich muss mal übrigens kurz in meine Mails gucken,
habe ich schon seit einer Woche nicht mehr reingeschaut, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Nachdem sie jetzt ja den ganzen Kram verschoben haben, muss natürlich auch Beta und
alle möglichen anderen Dinger,
verschoben werden.
AliExpress hat mir gerade eine Meldung geschickt.
Ihre Bestellung ist angekommen. Ja, ich weiß, sie ist schon eine Woche da.
Die China-Chinesen, Alter.
Okay, schauen wir uns das mal an. Lassen wir uns mal eine Runde LevelCapture baden.
Zack.
Leaked.
Ey, die PS5, die sieht aus wie dieser Roboter aus WALL-E.
Kennt ihr den?
WALL-E?
Äh, IWA, oder so hieß die doch.
EVE.
Genau! Die PS5 sieht original aus wie EVE.
WALL-E?
Ist, ist, finde ich, mit, äh, mit der beste Animationsfilm, den es gibt.
Das waren auch die Zeiten, wo sie wirklich richtig, äh, gute Filme rausgehauen haben.
WALL-E 2 braucht keiner.
Outhalowing Halo and much more.
New open beta dates for Battlefield 2042 have leaked.
The beta was supposed to happen this month before the game was delayed to November.
Leaker Tom Henderson claims the new open beta dates are October 6th for early access pre-order customers
and October 8th for everyone else.
DICE's global community manager...
Das da unten, das da unten kann ich weder B noch N stätigen, ja?
...customers and October 8th for everyone else.
DICE's global community manager said to expect more info about the beta later this month following the delay announcement, so we should have official news soon enough.
As for why the game is being delayed, one developer says he's working on tweaking terrain tessellation for max performance without sacrificing visual quality.
Terrain tessellation is essentially an effect that adds more detail and depth to surfaces.
Das ist ein Effekt, das mehr Detail und Depth an die Oberflächen erzeugt.
Und es ist ein ziemlich wichtiges Effekt in einem Spiel wie Battlefield.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch nicht so schlimm wird, wie das teilweise auf Reddit oder so gemalt wurde.
So nach dem Motto, die Beta war so mega enttäuschend und jetzt, wo sie es verschoben haben, haben sie sich ja eingestanden, dass das ja quasi doch genauso kacke immer noch ist wie in der Beta oder so.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also, der Beta-Stand, den man da gesehen hat, oder was heißt der Beta-Stand, dieser Testing-Playtest da mit...
Wo es ganz viel geleakt gab und so.
Das war definitiv ein monatelalter Bild.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, anders kann das auch überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man diesen Monat doch jetzt sinnvoll nutzen kann.
Vor allem Sachen zu fixen, Kleinigkeiten, die halt einfach kaputt sind und den Spielfluss und das Gameplay verunstalten.
Oder aber, was man ja auch machen kann ist, wenn man jetzt durch das Feedback, durch den Playtest und das, was die Leute geschrieben haben und gesehen hat,
dass man jetzt vielleicht die Auswahl hatte, hey, nehmen wir Weg A oder nehmen wir Weg B, aber, wie soll ich das jetzt beschreiben,
aber der, sag mal so, entwicklungstechnisch nicht viel Unterschied ist.
Also, sei es von Fahrzeughandling bis zu irgendwelchen Sachen, wo sie sich noch nicht so ganz sicher waren,
nehmen wir das, nehmen wir das, aber implementierungsmäßig ist es gar kein so großer Aufwand.
Oder man kann es relativ schnell umstricken.
Also, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie innerhalb von einem Monat ordentlich was machen.
Und, mal im Ernst, im Prinzip wäre das ja anderweitig auch genauso gelaufen.
Das Game wäre rausgekommen und die hätten dann erstmal einen Day-One-Patch rausgehauen, der riesengroß wäre,
und die hätten den nächsten Monat über nochmal 1-2 Riesen-Patches rausgehauen.
Also, im Prinzip kriegen wir das Game jetzt nach einem Day-One-Patch und 1-2 großen Patches.
Was jetzt halt nicht unbedingt dafür sorgt, dass wir bei Release keinen Day-One-Patch kriegen.
Den wird es so oder so geben.
Da können wir uns irgendwie, das ist ja mittlerweile...
Der gehörte zum guten Ton.
Ah, Day-One-Patch.
Stört mich nicht.
Mich stört es überhaupt nicht, dass es delayed wurde.
Stört mich überhaupt nicht.
Solange es was taugt.
Also, mir ist es lieber, es kommt ein Game raus.
Gerade Battlefield braucht das jetzt auch mal.
Wieder ein Game raus, was was taugt.
Als dass es einen Monat früher kommt.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Es gab eine Menge Kontroversien über eine Design-Revision, die Sony zu der PlayStation 5 gemacht hat.
Das neue CFI-1100-Modell der Konsole hat ein kleineres Heatsink-Design,
das ist deutlich leiser als die originalen Modelle und hat weniger Koffer,
was generell bedeutet, dass es nicht so viel Hektik verspüren wird.
Sony hat das Design als kostensavige Maßnahme verändert
und verkauft jetzt dieses Modell der PlayStation 5 als Profit,
dank des reduzierten Gewichts.
Initiale Teardowns der neuen Revision von Tech-Reviewern,
und z.B. Austin Evans,
haben sich auf das neue Design geäußert,
da es kleiner ist, generell ist es weniger,
wenn es um Heatsinks geht.
Ja, ja, gut.
Das stimmt ja schon.
In der Regel ist umso kleiner der Kühler, umso schlechter.
Aber, das kommt natürlich darauf an,
ob das Ding noch nach wie vor so viel Abwärme produziert.
Wer weiß, was da sonst noch sich geändert hat.
Vielleicht bessere Platzierung der Komponenten,
vielleicht irgendwie fertig.
Vielleicht wird der Fertigungsprozess verbessert, keine Ahnung.
Gab es noch irgendein AAA-Game, was in Plan rausgekommen ist wahrscheinlich?
Also, was ich ein bisschen lustig finde, ist, dass sie es auf Corona schieben.
Das halte ich ja z.B. für bescheuert.
Twitter, Battlefield, ich muss euch mal kurz die offizielle Meldung dazu zeigen.
Das ist natürlich unsinnig, das ist natürlich unsinnig.
Sie schreiben hier,
dass das Global Pandemic Unforeseen Challenges,
warum haben sie nicht geschrieben Unforeseen Consequences?
Da hätten sich zumindest die Half-Life-3-Leaker irgendwie freuen können.
Also, das halte ich für Schwachsinn.
Das halte ich für Schwachsinn, da jetzt Corona vorzuschieben.
Sie haben Anfang des Jahres, nee, Schwachsinn,
ich glaube gar nicht Anfang des Jahres, im Juni oder so haben die noch erzählt,
sie sind richtig gut dabei und haben schon viel mehr geschafft,
als sie eigentlich gedacht haben, bla bla bla.
Und da war ja Corona noch Volleffekt.
Ja, das ist schwachsinnig.
Das ist auch nichts, was man einen Monat vorher merkt.
Das sieht man ja.
Also, wenn die das wirklich erst einen Monat vorher merken,
dass es mit Corona nicht so läuft, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben,
dann sollte man jegliche Projektleiter und Manager direkt rausschmeißen.
Das kann nicht sein.
Also, das ist einfach nur vorgeschoben als so 0 nach 15 Grund,
den einem die Leute gerade gut abkaufen.
Also, mit Corona hat das garantiert nichts zu tun.
Vielleicht hat es,
vielleicht resultiert das irgendwie schon ein bisschen da draus,
aber das ist nichts, was ihnen jetzt erst aufgefallen ist.
Coronavirus, genau.
Es ist ja auch eine gute Begründung zur Zeit.
Wenn irgendwas delayt, kannst du einfach sagen, ja, Corona ist schuld.
Corona geht immer aktuell.
New Design have been put to rest by Digital Foundry,
working in collaboration with Gamers Nexus.
The two tech outlets put both the new and old PlayStation 5 revisions to the test,
benchmarking them in various conditions
and tearing them apart to do a physical analysis of the changes.
Their findings show no meaningful difference between the two heatsink designs.
If anything, the new design is slightly more efficient,
because it does a better job of cooling the PlayStation 5's VRMs.
The most recent update for Apex Legends wreaked havoc on the game's matchmaking servers.
Players have been getting disconnected about three times more than normal
following multiple update attempts to fix the issue.
This has prompted widespread outrage over the state of the game.
It's especially bad considering that there's a rank split coming
and the disconnects make you lose rank points.
The update launched as a mid-season event with new challenges
and paid cosmetics and made some pretty significant balance changes.
The server issue has persisted through multiple game updates
and Respawn is saying that the big fix players are hoping for it goes live on Monday.
Apex macht extrem viel Asche.
For the problems, they're expanding the current rank split by a week.
They haven't yet said the players will get their lost rank points back.
Splitgate's developers say that their game will get a Forge mode before Halo Infinite does.
The game is essentially a natural but plural Halo and Quake.
It exploded in popularity over the summer thanks to a cross-platform console beta.
It was so popular, in fact, that the devs had to rebuild their entire network infrastructure
to ensure that the game would be as popular as before.
Halo Infinite is launching this holiday season,
but won't get the franchise's iconic custom mode and map engine, Forge, until next year.
That was a big blow to fans eagerly awaiting the new Halo title.
343 also pushed the game's co-op campaign to a post-launch update.
Splitgate getting a Forge mode honestly sounds like an absolute win for players.
It already has a pretty decent custom mode system.
Combining that with the ability to craft custom maps
will give the game the chance to be able to play in real-time.
A splitgate version of Facing Worlds would be a ton of fun.
Especially if it's a bit competitive,
people will probably build better maps themselves than the official ones.
E-Sports fans got some great news.
Valve have confirmed their upcoming Stockholm CSGO Major is going ahead as planned.
It was previously postponed because of the country's Covid travel and public gathering restrictions.
Valve have been looking for another host country,
but Sweden recently relaxed its limitations,
and launched public events with many international attendees possible.
Tickets go on sale next week.
It'll be the biggest tournament in CSGO's history,
with a 2-million-dollar prize pool.
The event starts on October 26th.
By the way, now that I see this again,
does anyone remember that they wanted to compete with Overwatch?
That they wanted to compete with CS?
You can't say anything about that, right?
The arena opens for live matches on November 4th.
Valve also confirmed this year's Dota 2 International
event has moved to Romania.
Attendees must be fully vaccinated.
Man muss mal sagen, so kleine Nischen-Tournaments bei CS
haben mehr Zuschauer als die Overwatch League, Alter.
... and adhere to mask guidelines to enter the event.
It kicks off on October 7th, and the finals will start on the 16th.
Die müssen sich wegen Valorant warm anziehen.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten. Valorant-Event?
Es gibt ja kaum Valorant-Events.
Also CS ist da deutlich lebendiger als Valorant.
... open beta is open to anyone on PC with a battle.net account.
Reviews of the beta have been very mixed,
with most players saying audio quality is a problem.
Footstep audio and weapon sounds are muddy and hard to distinguish.
There's also problems with servers having issues keeping pace with the game.
Stuttering and crashing have been widely reported.
The good news is otherwise that the game itself seems pretty decent.
By all accounts, it's essentially a World War II-themed reskin
of Modern Warfare 2019.
If you like that game, chances are that you'll at least find Vanguard amazing.
Valheim is back with a vengeance thanks to the game's first major update,
finally going live after five months.
Hearth and Home adds a ton of new building parts, new items
and some big improvements to the overall experience.
All weapons have been rebalanced as well.
And while the game isn't exactly doing the same concurrent player count numbers
as we saw at launch, it's still doing exceptionally well,
thanks to the update.
Riot Games are releasing a new client for their games called,
wait for it, Riot Client.
Like most game developer clients,
they will let you manage all of your Riot titles with a single app.
It's launching early on September 20th
and all of their games will be integrated on October 4th.
You'll still be able to launch games with individual shortcuts
that don't require navigating the...
Valorant und LoL-Spieler-Kerz.
... the client itself.
An updated build of SteamOS has leaked,
to Valve shipping devkits of their new Steam Deck handheld console.
The Steam Deck's UI replaces...
Moment, wann sollte das eigentlich nochmal geliefert werden?
Man konnte das ja vorbestellen, wann sollte das geliefert werden?
... Big Picture Mode, which is a UI designed for navigating Steam
with a controller on your TV.
Under the hood, the UI is running on SteamOS 3,
a Linux build custom configured by Valve to support their games and software directly.
The UI and new build of SteamOS are still a work in progress,
so not all their functionality or features are available.
That said, the screenshot looks pretty promising
and consistent with Val's current refresh of Steam's desktop client.
The 10-year-old MMO Guild Wars 2 is getting a significant update
that adds DirectX 11 support.
Until now, it's only supported DirectX 9, preventing the game from utilizing...
Was? Guild Wars 2?
... hindering client performance.
And while DirectX 11 isn't exactly the new kid on the block,
it's a massive leap forward for the game
and will give the developers way more freedom to improve visuals
without sacrificing performance.
Despite its age, Guild Wars 2 still looks pretty good,
especially compared to other MMOs.
It's tough to say if the devs will do any major graphical upgrade in the near future,
but DirectX 11 support opens the doors for future improvements
that they could never accomplish with DirectX 9.
Before we get to the last news story of the week,
let me know in the comments what you thought was the craziest news of this week.
For me, personally, it was of course the Battlefield 2042 delay.
I was expecting it, but it's still kind of...
I played the beta, I didn't like it, but now it has to be a completely different game.
I can't say anything about Elder Scrolls Online.
The only thing that keeps me from trying out Elder Scrolls Online,
is that it probably has to be easy as fuck,
and more or less a singleplayer MMO, and that doesn't have to be.
Except for this PvP mode, but I don't really feel like it anyway.
... a shock that even after DICE being so far ahead of production schedule,
they had to delay the game.
Halo-Composer Marty O'Donnell has been found in contempt of court
over his unauthorized use of Destiny's music.
O'Donnell was fired by Bungie back in 2014, just before Destiny 1 launched.
He sued Bungie the following year and won a ruling that found Bungie
had overstepped in controlling his creative process.
The case was a big deal because O'Donnell is a co-founder of the studio
and being fired forced him to give up his shares of the company.
The ruling awarded him a portion of his stock options as cash,
which came with the stipulation that O'Donnell had to give up the rights
to the compositions he created for Destiny.
Things went sideways starting in 2019 when O'Donnell released music from his work
on Destiny via YouTube and music retailer Bandcamp.
Bungie served him in order to take down the music and pay almost $100,000 for selling it.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll see you next time.
This is LevelCap signing off.
Heute hat uns LevelCap gar nicht so sehr gebetet.
Nicht so überzogen.
Ja, genau das ist auch mein Eindruck von ESO.
Ich kann jetzt aber dazu halt aus erster Hand nichts sagen,
weil ich habe es nicht selbst gespielt.
Aber genau den Eindruck hatte ich halt auch,
dass ESO quasi eher das MMO ist für Leute,
die halt quasi ein Singleplayer Elder Scrolls spielen wollen
mit etwas Multiplayer Elementen.
Übrigens, bald kommt New World raus.
Bin mal gespannt, wie lange das MMO lebt,
ob zwei Monate oder ein halbes Jahr.
Okay, next.
Jetzt geben wir mal YouTube die Chance.
Geben wir mal YouTube die Chance zu refreshen.
Mal gucken, ob es irgendwas gescheites dabei ist.
So lange wie Crucible.
Der Vergleich hinkt.
Crucible hat noch nie gelebt.
Das war quasi schon dead.
Dead for release.
Aber wenn es 2,5 Millionen Server gibt,
die dafür im Internet public erreichbar sind,
dann haben die Leute aber absichtlich Mist freigegeben.
Weil standardmäßig ist dieses Omi-Zeug nicht im Internet erreichbar.
Das heißt, die haben absichtlich Firewall-Regeln gemacht
und ignorieren die Warnung im Azure-Dashboard,
dass sie das gemacht haben.
Dann sind wir gut.
Dann gehört sie nicht besser.
Und Fireship?
Reacting to controversial software opinions.
Object-oriented.
Okay, okay.
Oh je, da kann ich mich zu auslassen.
Geh ich davon aus. Zeig mal her.
Das stimmt.
Nö, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Oh, das Stack Overflow Survey 2021 müssen wir uns auch noch angucken.
Einfach mal ganz im Ernst.
Object-Orientierung ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
Da muss ich einfach nur überlegen,
eigentlich finde ich das eine recht sinnvolle Geschichte,
da muss ich halt nur überlegen,
dass man es nicht übertreibt.
Ich muss nicht alles irgendwie in Manager und Factories
und Klassen und Dings da kapseln.
Also ich brauche nicht eine...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen zum Beispiel,
der hat gezeigt, wie er ASP.NET Core Controller programmiert.
Und er hat gesagt, jeder Controller mit mehr als drei, vier Zeugen
oder vier Zeilen Code drin ist quasi nicht lesbar
und nicht solid und nicht objektorientiert genug, was auch immer.
Hat gemeint, sinngemäß nicht mehr als drei, vier Zeilen im Controller.
Das mag ja alles auf dem Papier schön und gut sein,
aber man muss das immer abwägen.
Also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise ein bisschen mehr Logik
an der einen Stelle brauche oder ob ich jetzt die Hälfte
meiner Architektur überdenken muss,
weil ich noch irgendwelche Zwischenschichten einziehen muss,
da schreibe ich halt fünf, sechs Zeilen mehr.
Ja, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Genauso wie ich auch die ganze Geschichte nicht verstehe,
was die Leute bei kleinen UI-Anwendungen,
sowas, was man heutzutage eigentlich nicht mehr macht,
weil man heute irgendwelche Browser-Geschichten macht,
aber irgendwelche kleinen lokalen UI-Geschichten,
sei es WPF, Windows Forms oder meinetwegen auch WPF,
ich weiß gar nicht, was die Leute gegen Code-Behind-Dateien haben.
Wenn das irgendwas ist,
wenn du ein paar GUI-Forms oder einer GUI-Form
und ein paar Inputs oder irgendwie eine Anzeige nimmst,
warum keine Code-Behind-Dateien? Wozu?
Was ist das Problem?
Was ist das Problem, was die Leute mit Code-Behind-Dateien haben,
wenn es um kleine Sachen geht?
Was für Dateien... Moment.
Code-Behind-Dateien sind, wenn du beispielsweise...
Code-Behind-Dateien sind, wenn du eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung anlegst
und deinen Code in die gleiche Datei schreibst,
wo auch dein GUI-Code mit drin ist.
Also wenn du das über den Assistent in Visual Studio machst,
dann sagst du hinzufügen, neues Form.
Und normalerweise ist dann in dieser Datei
bloß die Logik für die Forms oder auch bei WPF.
Und man kann natürlich in diese Datei,
wo die Logik für das GUI drin ist oder das Designer-Zeug,
kann man quasi in die Code-Behind-Datei reingehen
und da noch zusätzliche Sachen reinschreiben.
Und das ist dann quasi Code-Behind-Datei.
Das ist total verpönt. Ich verstehe nicht warum.
Wenn es für kleine Sachen ist, warum nicht?
Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Genauso wie man auch nicht für irgendwelche kleinen Webseiten,
irgendwelche CI, CD-Geschichten, Workflows und Kubernetes-Cluster
und haste-nicht-gesehen braucht.
Man muss es für kleine Sachen einfach nicht übertreiben.
Genau.
Es ist wichtig, dass man sich überlegt, was braucht man?
Was ist sinnvoll für das jeweilige Problem?
Wie kann man das am besten lösen?
Was ist die beste Technik dafür?
Und natürlich auch, wenn es dann mal größer wird,
dass man das dann irgendwie ordentlich machen kann.
Aber nachdem wir eh alle keinerlei Kommentare in Codes schreiben,
weil unser Code ja so aussagekräftig ist,
dass man keine Kommentare braucht,
haben wir auch das Problem alle nicht.
So, gucken wir uns mal an.
Was gibt es jetzt Neues?
...friendly and not toxic at all community.
...initial reaction based on...
Übrigens, weil ich es gerade im Chat sehe,
da muss ich jetzt gerade noch mal eine kleine Geschichte erzählen.
Hier.
Kein Kubernetes-Cluster für die Schulwebseite mit 100 Aufrufen.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wir hatten mal,
ich bin mir leider nicht mehr ganz sicher über die Aufrufe,
aber wir hatten mal ein Meeting, ist schon ein paar Jahre her,
da kamen irgendwelche Leute und haben gesagt,
ja, wir haben hier irgendwie eine neue Webapplikation am Start
und dafür brauchen wir einen richtig fetten Server.
Was ist denn so das Fetteste,
was ihr irgendwie besorgen könnt?
Na gut, müssen wir mal beim Rechenzentrumsbetriebleuten fragen,
was die haben, aber ich denke mal,
das Fetteste ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas, keine Ahnung,
2 Terabyte RAM und 64 Kerne und hast du nicht gesehen?
Also, wir haben schon ordentlich fette Kisten,
aber bevor wir so weit gehen, von was reden wir denn hier überhaupt?
Also, was ist das?
Ja, Web-Anwendung für den Außendienst
und braucht richtig fett Performance.
Die haben schon ordentlich Aufrufe,
die haben richtig viele Aufrufe.
Da habe ich dann gefragt, okay,
über wie viele Aufrufe reden wir hier denn?
Ja, und dann hat er, ich weiß leider die Zahl nicht mehr,
deswegen muss ich das jetzt ein bisschen improvisieren,
dann meinte er so 1000.
Dann sag ich so, oh, 1000, ja 1000, 1000 in was?
Am Tag.
Moment, langsam.
Ich weiß nicht, Leute, es kann auch sein, dass er zählt,
dass er auch 10.000 gesagt hat, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Es war zumindest am Tag und es war lächerlich.
Es war lächerlich.
Wo man wieder dabei ist, nur weil irgendjemand meint,
dass er das braucht, heißt es noch lange nicht,
dass er das wirklich braucht.
Lass es 10.000 am Tag gewesen sein, das ist eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Es war nichts, es war wirklich nichts.
Oh, Mann.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt, controversial opinions.
In years of experience, primarily in web development,
but in full disclosure, I only have about 5,000 rep on Stack Overflow.
Ich habe gar keinen rep on Stack Overflow,
ich habe nicht mal einen Stack Overflow account.
... doesn't really matter very much.
If you're new here, like and subscribe,
then leave your most controversial opinion
and I'll choose the best one to win a free T-shirt of your choice.
And I just released a whole bunch of new merch designs,
so check those out to support the channel
and keep this content coming.
... back to that initial opinion that basically says
object-oriented programming is working.
Nö, finde ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde überhaupt nicht, dass das suckt.
Gar nicht.
Man muss einfach pragmatisch an die Sache rangehen und gucken, okay,
was ist das Problem, was ich hier habe, wie kann ich das am besten lösen?
Und ich finde, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Zumal, und das ist jetzt auch eine ganz coole Geschichte,
zumal, wenn man sich mal Sprachen anguckt wie C Sharp zum Beispiel,
die ja als rein objektorientierte Sprache gestartet sind,
ich meine vielleicht nicht so krass wie Ruby,
Ruby ist ja quasi somit das objektorientierteste,
was du machen kannst,
aber selbst Ruby hat mittlerweile viele funktionale Sachen
und C Sharp auch.
Also, es ist mittlerweile eher so der Trend dahin,
dass die Sprachen so eher multi-paradigmenmäßig sind, ja?
Du kannst dann Sachen objektorientiert machen,
du kannst auch einige Sachen funktional angehaucht machen,
prozedural natürlich sowieso, ja.
So.
Ist das nicht, ist das nicht der Typ?
Ist das nicht der OSPF-Typ?
Also das, was sie in OSPF benutzen, zum Wege finden?
Das hat schon, Leute, ich muss sagen, das hat schon durchaus seinen Sinn,
dass man Sachen vererben kann und wiederverwenden kann.
Also gerade in Go, die ja sowas gar nicht haben,
ist es teilweise echt ätzend, wenn du Sachen drei- und viermal machen musst.
Wobei, doch, ein bisschen geht's in Go.
Also, das hat, das hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung.
In addition, there are a bunch of design patterns to go along with it.
Und gerade Interface ist die beste Erfindung.
All these features and design patterns sound sophisticated
and sometimes they trick you into thinking you're making productivity gains
when there's likely a much simpler way to get the job done.
A common complaint is that object-oriented languages require
a lot more boilerplate than something that's more functional in nature.
And applications end up having a bunch of mutable state
that's difficult to test, re-factor.
Also, a bit more boilerplate is there,
but especially when it comes to .NET and C-Sharp,
Microsoft is working very hard to reduce that.
You mustn't forget that in .NET 6, or even now, since .NET 5,
a minimal C-Sharp-Program is almost as long as a minimal Python-Program.
So, one line.
Nothing more with public, static, main, args,
gedöns, namespace, kannst du alles knicken.
Warum findest du Interfaces gut?
Weil du mit Interfaces vermeiden kannst, dass du Sachen miteinander verknotest,
die man nicht miteinander verknoten sollte.
Deswegen sind Interfaces ganz praktisch.
Das heißt, das Code kann gelöscht werden, wenn es zusammengebundelt ist.
Du musst dir auch nicht darum kümmern, was für Konstrukte, Getter, etc. ist.
Beispiel.
Boah, äh, okay, ähm, keine Ahnung.
Du nimmst, du hast, du hast irgendwas, was eine Connection,
irgendein Netzwerk-Connection managt, so.
Und da drüber willst du verschiedene Sachen ausführen.
Das heißt, du hast irgendwie, du hast irgendeine Klasse base-command
oder irgendwie sowas.
Äh, wo dann drinsteht die Information,
was du ausführen willst, und du hast eine Klasse,
die quasi die, die diese, deine, deine Netzwerkverbindung managt
für, äh, die eigentliche Datenübertragung, so.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, muss deine Command-Klasse
die Netzwerk-Management-Klasse kennen und umgedreht?
Das ist ja in der Regel keine gute Idee, wenn du sagst,
hey, Klasse A kennt Klasse B, aber Klasse B kennt auch Klasse A.
Das kann man machen, ja, das ist kein, gar kein, gar kein Problem.
Äh, wenn das auch zwei Dinger sind, die, die zusammengehören.
Aber oftmals ist es tatsächlich besser,
man übergibt weder Klasse A direkt an Klasse B,
noch irgendwie Parent-Klasse zurück an A,
sondern man macht einfach ein Interface,
was quasi so, so, so die Essenz der Funktionen,
die du haben willst, ja, äh, vorgibt, so nach dem Motto,
ich bin ein Parser, ich bin ein, äh, ich bin eine Netzwerk-Connection,
ich bin ein Command.
Und dann musst du die Klasse gar nicht mehr übergeben,
sondern einfach nur noch das Interface.
Und der weitere Vorteil davon ist, dass du mit Interfaces
viel mehr, äh, mit Generics anstellen kannst in C-Sharp
als beispielsweise mit Klassen.
Aber ich gebe zu, dass man gerade am Anfang
gar nicht so sehr sich mit Interfaces beschäftigen muss.
Ja, also, ja, mir fällt jetzt leider gar kein wirklich gutes, gutes,
gutes, richtig griffiges Beispiel ein.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wenn wir wieder was basteln.
Es ist, fällt mir jetzt wirklich kein, kein richtig griffiges Beispiel dazu ein.
Müssen wir mal Gedanken zu machen.
Okay, jetzt lass uns mal das Video durchgucken.
Kann ich alle fünf Sekunden Stop drücken?
...which in many cases just add unnecessary complexity.
But that being said, I do come across cases,
where a class is a really nice way to encapsulate something.
Ja, das ist auch so.
And they do work really well in frameworks like Angular or Nest,
that have put a lot of thought into how to work with classes
in a predictable way.
And there's also other tools out there that I really like
that are fundamentally object-oriented,
like Flutter or the Unity Framework.
When done properly, object-oriented programming
can be very nice and intuitive.
Ja, ich sehe da überhaupt kein Problem drin.
...so it's good to keep an open mind about procedural
or functional approaches as well.
Deswegen, deswegen ist ja das Gute,
und auch das, was man in den heutigen,
zumindest meist doch recht verbreitenden Sprachen sieht,
dass du da mehrere Sachen machen kannst.
Du kannst, Rust ist relativ funktional,
oder Go ist auch relativ funktional,
aber es hat trotzdem ein bisschen was Objektorientiertes dabei.
C-Sharp ist rein als Objektorientiertes gestartet.
Ruby auch, hat heute aber einige funktionale Elemente.
Also, muss man sagen, das ist eigentlich die beste Variante,
wenn du das verwenden kannst,
was halt für die jeweilige Situation am besten ist.
Ja.
Ja, sehe ich so.
Ich denke, dass das wirklich so ist.
...here is that if you're not passionate enough about coding
to do it in your spare time,
you're never going to reach your full potential.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist so.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist so.
...I think the reality is that many people treat programming as a job,
and there's absolutely nothing wrong with that.
Da sage ich auch nichts dagegen.
Da sage ich, ich habe damit, ich sage nicht,
dass das jemand machen muss.
Ja, das ist gar nicht die Frage.
Ich sage nicht, dass man die Leute dazu zwingen sollte,
das privat zu machen.
Wenn sie keinen Bock drauf haben, ist das okay.
Ja.
Aber wenn du Leute hast, die sich in ihrer Freizeit
mit dann wirklich den interessanten Dingen,
die sie persönlich interessiert, auch beschäftigt,
nur dann entwickelst du dich irgendwie auch weiter.
Wenn du den ganzen Tag die 23. Factory-Connection-Manager-Class
programmierst, dann vielleicht nicht.
...with a fraction of the effort that other programmers might need.
Und selbst Fortbildungen auf der Arbeit ersetzen das nicht.
Fortbildungen sind in der Regel PowerPoint-Geschwätz.
Ja, mit ein bisschen Fingerübung zwischendurch.
Richtig lernen tust du Sachen, wenn du dich,
wenn du persönlich daran interessiert bist
und dich tief in das Problem einarbeitest, um es zu verstehen
und dann am Ende auch rausgehst und sagst, okay,
jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum die das in Software
a so und so gemacht haben,
weil man es mal selbst versucht hat zu implementieren
und deswegen dann mal draufgekommen ist, aha,
ist ja eigentlich ganz logisch.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt, warum haben Suchmaschinen
so ein Problem mit Wildcards am Anfang?
Also sprich, warum kann man in Suchmaschinen oftmals
cute Chat suchen, aber nur ziemlich schwer cute Chat,
so mit Wildcards.
Das habe ich mich eine ganze Weile gefragt.
Also sprich, warum ist das hier, warum ist das hier okay
und warum ist das hier schlecht?
Das habe ich nie kapiert, bis ich mal selbst versucht habe,
so minimal eine Suchmaschine zu programmieren.
Und dann ist mir das relativ schnell eingeleuchtet,
warum das so ist, warum das Ganze nicht funktioniert.
Suchmaschinen sind in der Regel, zumindest der Einstieg in diesen Baum,
aber es ist kein Baum, das stimmt ja nicht.
Also zumindest, zumindest der Einstieg in diesem,
in den Index aus Postings und Positions und sowas,
Index ist ja das richtige Wort.
Der Einstieg in den Index ist eine sortierte Liste.
Das heißt, alle Suchbegriffe, die man hat, sind alphabetisch geordnet.
Also sprich, Google hat intern einen Index über alle Suchbegriffe
und die ist alphabetisch geordnet.
Das heißt, der Begriff, die Begriffe mit A,
kommen am Anfang, ja?
Also, so, nacheinander.
Und davor kommen wahrscheinlich Zahlen oder was auch immer.
Und deswegen ist es so schwierig, Wildcards am Anfang zu machen.
So, also keine Ahnung.
Das Wort A, B, C, Alpha oder was auch immer,
kommt vor Bravo,
kommt vor Butter und was auch immer.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht, das kommt danach.
So, also das ist Alpha zu Lull, kommt zum Schluss.
So, also das ist, Suchbegriffe sind aufsteigend geordnet.
Das ist eine sortierte Liste.
So, und wenn ich jetzt ein Wildcard,
und wie das jetzt, wie eine Suche funktioniert,
ist erstmal, du nimmst den ersten Buchstaben
von einem Suchbegriff und guckst, wo geht's los.
Und damit du das Ganze machen kannst,
machst du das mit einer Binary Search.
Binary Search ist quasi immer die Hälfte,
immer die Hälfte nehmen.
So nach dem Motto, ich gehe in die Mitte der Liste,
guck, ist das, was ich suche, größer oder kleiner?
Also ich suche jetzt hier beispielsweise das Wort,
was mit C anfängt.
Das ist größer oder kleiner?
Okay, größer.
Also nehme ich die nächste Hälfte,
guck, ist es größer oder kleiner?
Und dann bleibt nur noch das eine übrig.
Das heißt, ich weiß in dem Fall, ich habe es nicht gefunden,
beziehungsweise, ähm,
ich bin dann relativ schnell an der Position,
wo ich es finde, die Einträge hier zu meinem Suchbegriff.
Und wenn ich ein Wildcard am Anfang habe,
dann funktioniert das nicht.
Wenn ich ein Wildcard am Anfang von meinem Suchbegriff habe,
dann kann ich nicht durch meine Liste durchgehen,
weil ich nicht Binary Search mal machen kann.
Das heißt, ich muss, damit Wildcards am Anfang funktionieren,
linear durch die ganze Liste meiner Suchbegriffe suchen.
So, und deswegen, das sind so Sachen,
die kapiert man nur, wenn man sich damit auseinandersetzt,
warum manche Sachen eben so sind.
Ja, weil du es mal selbst programmiert hast.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe es nie verstanden,
aber jetzt schon, weil ich es mal selbst probiert habe.
Ein zweiter umgedrehter Index alleine bringt dir ja auch nichts.
Das bringt dir nur was, da kannst du es vielleicht halbieren,
weil du dann von oben in einem Thread und vom unteren im anderen Thread
oder wie auch immer anfangen kannst zu suchen.
Aber du bist auf jeden Fall langsamer.
Also, wenn du eine lange Liste hast und dein Suchbegriff ist irgendwo in der Mitte,
ob du jetzt zwei Listen linear durchsuchen musst oder eine,
ja, das macht es dann, je nachdem, das macht es dann schon schneller,
aber weit nicht so schnell wie so. Oder was meinst du?
Ach so, bei der zweiten Datenbank ist das letzte Zeichen das erste.
Ja gut, das kann man auch machen.
Also, wie gesagt, es gibt natürlich da Lösungen dafür.
Was man so treiben kann.
Aber das ist erstmal so grundsätzlich die Erklärung,
warum es mit Wildcards am Anfang schlechter funktioniert.
Gut, das ist wohl wahr, das ist wohl wahr.
Aber Leute, die einfach nur gut schwätzen können und eigentlich ihren Job nicht können,
brauchst du auch nicht.
Es ist gut, wenn die Leute sozial verträglich sind, natürlich.
Ich habe auch keinen Bock, mit irgendwelchen Idioten zusammenzuarbeiten.
Und es ist auch gut, wenn man halbwegs normal mit den Leuten reden kann.
Ja, alles keine Frage.
Und wenn die das halbwegs normal erklären können, was sie gemacht haben.
Also, alles kein Ding.
Aber du brauchst keinen Programmierer, der 90 Prozent labern kann
und 10 Prozent programmieren.
Das ist, das ist unsinnig.
Ja.
Aber Programmierer ja eh das falsche Wort in der heutigen Zeit ist.
Wir sind ja heute alle Full-Stack-Biz-Sec-DevOps.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Das ist auch so.
Bin ich der festen Überzeugung.
Das ist so.
Ja.
Na.
So Glück.
Ja.
Man könnte auch sagen, gründlich.
Also ich versuche, sagen.
Ich bin mega.
Ihr kennt mich.
Ja, ich bin mega faul.
Alles, alles was ich mache.
Ich mache eigentlich nichts.
Nichts wirklich gerne aus eigenem Antrieb, wenn es Arbeit bedeutet.
Ja.
Aber wenn ich was mache, aber wenn ich was mache, dann will ich, dass mich nie wieder
jemand damit nervt.
Und dementsprechend versuche ich das dann auch.
dann auch insofern in die Zukunft zu denken,
was könnte denn alles passieren,
dass ich den Scheiß einmal machen muss und nie wieder.
Das Bild mit der Kugel ist doof, warum?
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ja gut, okay, das ist tatsächlich ein doofes Bild.
Das stimmt, weil das und das
sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Dinger.
Wenn derjenige, der hier am Ende sitzt,
hier so einen Quader da bestellt hat
oder einen Würfel bestellt hat,
dann will er auch einen Würfel haben und keine Kugel.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
wenn die daraus irgendwas bauen wollen oder sonst was,
hat er hier natürlich viel weniger dran als da.
Also da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Aber klar, was es damit sagen will, ist logisch.
Aber da kann man sich drüber streiten,
ob das Bild wirklich eine gute Aussagekraft hat.
Ja, Pyramide bauen geht damit zum Beispiel nicht,
selbst wenn er als erstes da ist.
Das habe ich gelaufen.
Ja, also,
ich glaube, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich finde, so sollte man das machen.
Nee, nee, Moment mal, das ist falsch.
Wir sollten das NPM-Package verwenden.
Is odd, is even.
Einfach NPM install, is odd.
Wir brauchen das überhaupt nicht selbst zu machen.
Wie heißt du auf Discord?
Gute Frage, weiß ich nicht, warum.
Ich weiß es gerade wirklich nicht.
Max?
Nee.
Warum?
Du kannst einfach bei uns den Discord-Server joinen.
Da bin ich immer am Start.
Da bin ich, ich bin da jeden Tag.
Ich schreibe nicht immer was, aber ich bin da jeden Tag.
Ich gucke, dass da nicht Leute wieder irgendwelche komischen, äh,
Rule...
Was ist das, Rule 34, Bilder posten oder sowas?
Wo ist eigentlich das eben?
Varro.
In some cases, learning might even be a waste of time.
The next opinion is that googling it is okay.
Natürlich, natürlich ist Google okay.
Google ist nicht nur okay, Google ist das Wichtigste, was man können muss.
My doctor told me that googling stuff online doesn't make me a doctor.
Das vielleicht nicht, aber, ähm, also, ich meine, ich würde natürlich ein bisschen doof gucken,
wenn mein Arzt erstmal sagt, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz, äh, äh, googeln,
bevor ich sie, äh, ab, abhöre, ne, so basic Sachen schon,
aber ansonsten machen das Ärzte garantiert auch.
Die wissen auch nicht aus dem Kopf jedes nur erdenkliche Medikament oder Zusammensetzung oder was auch immer.
Ja, das machen die auch.
Die machen im Prinzip das Gleiche, was Programmierer auch machen.
Du, oder, oder was du als Programmierer oder generell jemand, der in der IT, in der Technik arbeitet, auch kennen musst.
Du musst genug von den Basics verstehen und genug vom eigentlichen Problem verstehen,
dass du weißt, nach was du suchen musst.
Ja, genau.
Ich stimme diesem Meinung, weil die tägliche Arbeit der meisten Entwickler ist,
um Probleme für das Geschäft zu lösen, anstatt mehr theoretische Algorithmen-Implementationen,
die du in einer Interview befindest.
Google ist nicht die Lösung für alles, aber zu wissen, wie man es effizienter nutzen kann,
ist definitiv ein Fähigkeit, das jeder Erwachsenen-Developer haben sollte.
Auf eine relevantere Seite, eine andere kontroversielle Meinung ist,
dass ein Degret in Computer-Science dich eine mehr gut geschraubt hat,
ja.
Da kann man sich jetzt wirklich drüber streiten. Also es kommt darauf an, was du machst. Also ich würde nicht pauschal sagen, es ist Schwachsinn oder es ist richtig. Also je nachdem, was du machst. Wenn du jetzt irgendwelche CSS, HTML, Frontend-Buttons und so, also wenn du so Sachen machst, dann glaube ich, ist wahrscheinlich mehr Praxiserfahrung wichtiger.
Wenn du aber ein bisschen, soll ich sagen, grundlegendere Computer-Science-Geschichten machst, also wenn du beispielsweise, sagen wir sowas, du arbeitest an einer Suchmaschine oder du musst vielleicht schauen, Performance-Optimierung, da ist es schon nicht verkehrt, wenn du weißt, okay, wie kannst du ungefähr Laufzeiten abschätzen oder vielleicht ist es bescheuert, alles in eine Liste zu schreiben.
Vielleicht ist eine Hash-Map beziehungsweise ein Dictionary deutlich sinniger in dem Fall für die Zugriffszeiten. Das hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Du brauchst es auch nicht. Du brauchst es nicht, aber das kann durchaus in gewissen Bereichen Vorteile haben, klar. Wohingegen in anderen Bereichen Praxiserfahrung deutlich wichtiger ist. Das kann man so pauschal weder Ja noch Nein sagen.
Everything is available basically for free. You can learn anything you want for free.
Na, wenn das Elon Musk sagt, dann muss es ja stimmen.
And many big companies have dropped their degree requirements for developers altogether.
Personally, I don't have a computer science degree. Everything I've learned has been self-taught or learned on the job.
And I've met many other developers making big salaries without a degree.
So you definitely don't need a degree to break into the industry.
But that being said, if I could go back in time, I would probably pursue a computer science degree.
It can definitely fast-track you by getting you internships at big companies.
And I do think that's a good thing.
A foundation of knowledge would likely make you a better programmer.
But on the other hand, is it really worth four years of your time and a hundred thousand dollars in student debt?
Hau drauf an!
College definitely isn't a path for everybody.
And one of my favorite things about the tech industry is that you can be successful without a degree.
Which is a good segue into the next opinion.
There's an awful lot of bad teaching out there.
Whether you have a degree or not, you'll eventually find yourself on YouTube trying to learn from one of the many different...
Also es gibt online viel Schwachsinn. Es gibt sehr viel Schwachsinn.
Das ist aber wie bei allem, dass 80, 90...
80% der Sachen suckt und man muss einfach das Gute, das Gute finden.
Das kannst du übertragen von Handwerker auf Ärzte auf Programmierer. 80, 90% sind kacke.
Du musst die guten Leute finden.
...teachers out there.
As a teacher myself and a supporter of my fellow YouTubers, I unfortunately agree with this statement.
In fact, plenty of people out there absolutely hate my teaching style.
You suck!
I get mean comments on almost every video, saying the content sucks and that it's too fast and so on.
What it really boils down to is that different people...
have different preferences when it comes to teaching style.
Ironically, the biggest turn off for me is when a teacher has a highly opinionated take on something.
There are people out there who preach dogma like there's only one right way to do something.
Das finde ich auch nicht gut.
That's almost never the case and my mind is...
Das ist das Gleiche, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, so nach dem Motto, niemals Code-Behind-Dateien verwenden und sowas.
Warum nicht? Ja, es gibt durchaus Anwendungsszenarien.
Die meisten sogar, die meisten bauen keine super komplexe Business-GUI-Geschichten, sondern irgendwas Kleines.
Warum nicht?
Es gibt sogar...
Jetzt kommt mal eine kontroverse Meinung, ja?
Ich wollte es auch gerade sagen, der Chat sagt schon, ich bin sogar der Meinung, man kann Go-To verwenden.
Und es ist gar nicht mal schlecht in den passenden Situationen.
Selbst Go-To hat seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ich meine, man muss seine Sache nicht zukleistern mit Go-Tos, das sage ich nicht.
Aber selbst Go-To kann an der richtigen Stelle angewendet durchaus sein.
Es kann auch etwas sinnvoll sein.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie drei nested Schleifen habe und habe in der inneren Schleife irgendeine Bedingung, dass ich aus allen raus will.
Das ist zum Beispiel genau sowas hier in der Richtung, ja?
Das ist zum Beispiel eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Da kann man das verwenden.
Und dann zu sagen, nein, ich mache lieber zig Ifs und Breaks und sonst was.
Warum?
Ja, nur weil irgendwie der Oberguru gesagt hat, Go-To ist immer schlecht.
Das ist doch schwachsinnig.
Was übrigens Sokrates niemals überliefert gesagt hat.
Ich glaube, ihm wird das ja zugeschrieben.
Sokrates, von dem gibt es ja kaum was.
Oh, Moment, jetzt habe ich irgendwas.
Oh, Unit-Testing.
Quatsch.
Ich brauche keine Tests.
Test ist bloat.
Also, unsere Software ist prinzipiell, braucht keine Kommentare und keine Tests.
Weil wir programmieren so, dass es für sich selbst steht.
Und dementsprechend ist es auch für jeden verständlich und hat keine Bugs.
Deswegen braucht man dafür auch keine Tests.
Ist ganz einfach.
Was meint ihr denn, wie viel Zeit man spart mit self-documented Code, der einfach immer perfekt funktioniert?
Man braucht keine Tests.
Also, man braucht keine Unit-Tests.
Man braucht keine Tests am Ende irgendwie, ob es funktioniert oder was auch sonst was.
Nein, man programmiert einfach und es ist instant fertig und man kann es ausliefern.
Einfach keine Fehler machen.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Das Meme-Board hat keine Bugs.
Nee, es hat überhaupt keine Bugs.
Es hat nur Features.
Das ist alles gewollt.
Und manchmal gar nicht.
Unit-Test kann sehr wertvoll sein.
Und es gibt sogar empirische Beweise, um das zu unterstützen.
Aber auch in meiner Erfahrung kann es ein völlig unnötiger Wartezeit sein.
Besonders in Projekten, in denen die Anforderungen nicht sehr gut definiert und möglich sind, sich zu verändern.
Also meine Meinung dazu, vielleicht jetzt mal ernsthaft, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Natürlich sind Tests sinnvoll.
Aber nicht nur Tests, um Tests zu haben.
Also, wenn ich eh nur das teste.
Oder lass mal überlegen, wie sage ich das jetzt am besten?
Also ich muss das testen, was kaputt gehen kann.
Ich muss nicht testen, ob die Implementierung von C-Sharp 1 gleich gleich 1 funktioniert.
Oder solche Geschichten.
Und ich brauche auch nicht den gleichen Test dreimal nur mit anderer Beschreibung.
Oder wie soll ich das sagen?
Also halt an sinnvollen Stellen.
Eventuell auch da, wo vielleicht schon öfters mal was kaputt gegangen ist.
Das ist genauso.
Das ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie mit Kommentaren.
Das ist ähnlich wie mit Comments.
Also ich brauche ja auch kein...
Ja?
Windows?
What the fuck?
Warum ist das broken?
Okay.
Alter, Windows.
Visual Studio.
Was passiert, wenn ich da jetzt enter...
Aha!
Funktioniert.
Funktionieren tut es anscheinend noch.
Okay, dann mache ich den Klingelchat mal.
Also was natürlich sinnlos ist.
So.
Was natürlich sinnlos ist, ist wenn ich hier sowas mache.
If...
Hallo, Visual Studio.
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
Äh...
Was weiß ich.
True gleich gleich 1 oder sowas.
Es ist egal, ob das geht.
Und ich dann einen Kommentar drüber schreibe.
Checks if true is equal 1.
Ne, das ist bescheuert.
Das ist komplett, komplett bescheuert.
Also das braucht kein Mensch als Kommentare.
Das machen Leute gerne, die quasi das in der Schule lernen.
Und wenn der Lehrer dann sagt, so nach dem Motto.
Für jede Zeile mindestens eine Zeile Comments oder sowas.
Oder nehmen wir mal was hier.
Guck mal, hier habe ich doch irgendwas gebastelt.
Es hat zum Beispiel absolut keinen Sinn, wenn ich hier drüber schreibe.
Prince Result oder sowas.
Das sehe ich.
Das muss ich da drüber schreiben.
Ich meine, jemand, der das hier sieht.
Meint die erst, dem ist nicht klar.
Dass das das Result ausgibt.
Das ist, das ist genauso.
Oder wenn ich hier drüber schreibe.
Initiate new call oder so.
Das ist komplett Sinn.
Oder wenn ich hier drüber schreibe.
Wait for.
Okay, wenn ich, wenn ich das hier hinschreibe.
Wait for 2,5 seconds.
Das hat sogar in gewisser Weise noch einen Mehrwert.
Für alle, die zu blöd sind.
2500 Millisekunden in 2,5 Sekunden umzurechnen.
So.
Ja.
Jetzt machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Jetzt, jetzt machen wir mal, jetzt machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Wo ein Kommentar eventuell sinnvoll wäre.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel hier.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Ich weiß auch, ich weiß, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich gemeint habe.
Also ein sinnloser Kommentar ist sowas, was weiß ich.
Except from any source oder so.
Das wäre jetzt bescheuert.
Das kann ich sehen.
Wenn ich da beispielsweise hinschreibe.
Warum?
Ja.
Wenn ich da zum Beispiel irgendwie sowas hinschreiben würde wie.
We need to accept connections from was weiß ich.
Azure bla bla bla bla bla.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Wir gehen mal davon aus, das hätte damit was zu tun.
Ja.
Das nochmal hervorzuheben, warum man das macht, wenn man das normalerweise nicht macht.
Warum man beispielsweise sagt, wir müssen Connections von überall accepten.
Das ist klar.
Warum?
Weil wir Verbindungen von außen, keine Ahnung, von irgendeinem Azure Service bekommen.
Dann finde ich das durchaus sinnvoll, das, das, das hinzuschreiben.
Ja.
Und bei Tests ist es im Prinzip ähnlich.
So, weiter.
Ja.
Das ist übrigens auch was.
Was war denn das?
Oh, ich werde gehostet.
Dankeschön.
Kapuzenboy.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig gelesen habe.
Der Kapuzenboy hat mich gehostet.
Dankeschön für den Host.
Wo bin ich denn jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ja, willkommen Leute vom Kapuzenboy.
Der hat das Ganze aus dem Takt gebracht.
Tests, Comments, was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade loswerden?
Ja, also man sollte halt reinschreiben dort, wo es nicht offensichtlich ist.
Ja.
Dann macht es mit Comments Sinn.
Und mit Tests ist es ähnlich.
Ach, genau.
Change my requirements.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch was, wo ich persönlich nicht allzu viel von halte.
Das ist auch kontroverse Meinung, gebe ich zu.
Es gibt ja so den Ansatz, bevor man auch nur eine Zeile programmiert, programmiert man die Tests dafür.
Ich bin der Meinung, das funktioniert nicht.
Vielleicht habt ihr irgendwelche Gegenbeispiele, wo ihr sagt, jawohl, das klappt wunderbar.
Ich glaube, die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo dazwischen.
Es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, eine Vorstellung davon zu haben, was man machen muss im Vorfeld.
Ja.
Oder eventuell auch schon für die wichtigsten Sachen ein paar Tests zu passen.
Aber zu sagen, bevor ich nicht für alles einen Test habe, fange ich nicht an zu programmieren, ist praktisch nicht umsetzbar.
Ja, und übrigens Tests, das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch sagen.
Tests, die ich auch nicht gut finde, sind Tests, die man jedes Mal anpassen muss, wenn es einen Fehler gibt.
Also.
Zum Beispiel, man möchte, man teste den Return-Wert von irgendwas.
So.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich dort irgendwas dran ändere, passe ich auch automatisch meinen Test an, dass der Test wieder grün ist.
Das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck von Tests.
Die Tests sollen was testen, was eben, wo mir klar ist, dass das so sein muss.
Wenn ich jedes Mal immer Code plus Tests anpassen muss, sollte man sich vielleicht überlegen, ob der Test nicht überflüssig ist.
Weil, wo ist der Sinn?
Weil, wo ist der Sinn von, wenn ich mit jeder Code-Änderung eine Test-Änderung brauche, dass der Test wieder grün wird?
So.
Wollen wir mal weiter.
Controversial Opinions.
Back to your code, but also your tests.
In addition, most developers don't really like writing tests in the first place.
Ja.
Ich gebe zu, ich mag auch keine Tests.
The requirement now, like 95% code coverage.
Wenn man einen Parser programmiert, kann es zu viele Kommentare geben.
Das kommt auf deinen Parser an.
Und wie?
Und wie offensichtlich, wie offensichtlich die Sachen sind.
Ja.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwas, ja, wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwo eine Liste anlegst, um da irgendwelche Tokens reinzuschreiben, da musst du nicht, musst du nicht da drüber schreiben, hier, instantiate new list oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Wenn du allerdings explizit hervorheben möchtest, dass dein Parser an manchen Stellen dafür quasi neuen Speicher allokieren muss.
Wenn du denkst, hey, das muss ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Performancetechnisch will ich das hervorheben, dann schreib es rein.
Das muss ja derjenige, der das programmiert, wissen im Endeffekt.
Es gibt da eh kaum was Einheitliches, ja.
Wenn du mich fragst, ich sag so.
Wenn du einen anderen fragst, der sieht es ein bisschen anders.
Deswegen ist auch ganz wichtig, finde ich, was er hier am Anfang gesagt hat.
Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn euch irgendjemand erzählt, das muss immer so sein oder es darf nie so sein.
Du darfst nie go to verwenden zum Beispiel oder nie code behind Dateien oder so.
Ist, finde ich, ziemlich unsinnig.
Also.
Einfach das, was angemessen ist.
You get a bunch of pointless tests just for the sake of testing and horrible code to go along with it.
I think quality is a lot more important than quantity when it comes to testing.
Or if you have the resources, use a dedicated quality.
Ja, Moment, Moment.
Das ist ja auch komplett was anderes.
Wenn du schon was hast, ja.
Was ist immer denn hier?
Ja, wenn du schon was hast, was quasi irgendeine fette Anwendung mit was weiß ich 250.000 Zeilen, die komplex als fuck ist und eh schon kaum noch einer drückt.
Klar, dass du da eine Reihe von Tests hast, die das abklopft, das sag ich ja überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Was ich gemeint habe, ist diese Geschichte mit, du fängst erst gar nicht an zu programmieren, bevor du nicht irgendwie Tests für alle Fälle hast.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Das klappt, ich hab nirgends wo, ihr könnt mir gerne was anderes erzählen, aber ich bezweifle, dass das funktioniert.
Wenn du natürlich was großes, komplexes hast, dann sag ich da gar nichts gegen.
Und gerade für, und gerade an Stellen, wo öfters schon mal was in die Hose gegangen ist.
Aber ja, du hast insofern recht, also meine Erfahrung wirklich mit richtig großen Anwendungen, mit richtig großen Teams hält sich tatsächlich in Grenzen.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das anders ist.
Da hast du ja noch mehr Probleme, wenn du erst komplett anfängst, wenn du für alles Tests hast.
Aber selbst da, ich kann mir, selbst in Medizin, selbst in der, ey, selbst in der Raumführung.
Ja, genau.
Wo es darum geht, wo irgendwelche Raketen gesteuert werden oder sowas.
Da kann mir keiner erzählen, dass die erst die erste Zeile programmieren, nachdem sie einen Test dafür haben.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Wir haben eigentlich gar keine Ahnung genau, was wir machen wollen, beziehungsweise mit welchen Libraries, mit welcher Sprache, mit wie auch immer.
Aber bevor wir auch nur anfangen, Tests zu machen, also zu testen, zu evaluieren, zu testen.
Programmieren wir erst mal Tests oder so.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich glaube, die Wahrheit liegt, wie immer, irgendwo in der Mitte.
Ja, es gibt ja noch gar keine anderen Stellen, weil du hast ja noch gar nicht angefangen zu programmieren.
Nee, also ich glaube, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich irgendjemand gibt, der das hundertprozentig durchzieht.
Und außerdem ohne, was heißt Gantt-Diagramm?
Struktogramm, Alter.
Ohne Struktogramm geht schon mal gar nichts.
Ja.
Nassi-Schneiderman-Struktogramm, bitteschön.
Ja, das ist immer was anderes.
Ja gut, wobei, irgendwo musst du ja mal anfangen.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Es ist wichtig, dass gerade an den Stellen, wo es business-technisch große Auswirkungen hat, wenn was kaputt geht, oder eben Sachen, die schon öfters mal kaputt gegangen sind, dass das
ähm
sowohl
logikseitig getestet ist,
aber auch
nicht nur, also es reicht ja nicht, wenn du irgendwelche Unit-Tests hast, die dann im Endeffekt gucken, okay, kommt da das Richtige raus, wenn ich das Richtige reinstecke,
ähm,
das müssen auch echte Leute testen.
Und das in Kombination ist, glaube ich, vollkommen ausreichend.
Genau.
Korrekt.
Ich sage ja, hundertprozentig ergibt keinen Sinn.
Wenn du eine halbwegs ordentliche Testabdeckung hast, ist das, ist das doch in Ordnung.
Von hundert Prozent,
das ist ja das, was ich meine.
Dieses, diese, diese dogmatische Sache, dass du sagst, das muss so sein und ich schreibe keine Zeile, bevor es einen Test gibt, das kann einfach nicht funktionieren.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, da sind wir wieder beim Thema, das sieht wahrscheinlich jeder ein bisschen anders.
Ich würde mich nur wundern, wenn das wirklich irgendwo so ist.
Dankeschön für eine Trillionen
Bits, SebiX86.
Bald gibt es keine Updates mehr für dich.
Profitiere von der Cloud.
Bau TestChamp.
Einfach Geld verlangen und random Coverage-Zahlen zurückliefern.
Oh, das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Der TestChamp.
CoverageChamp.
Es gibt, also es gibt ja, es gibt ja Tools, die machen sowas schon für dich.
Aber die, die versuchen das realistisch einzuschätzen.
So nach dem Motto, ähm, so und so viele Teile von deinem Code sind von Tests abgedeckt.
Das, das gibt's ja schon.
Aber das ist ja, das ist ja realitätsbezogen.
Die, die versuchen ja, ähm,
ähm, raus, rauszubekommen, was wirklich der Fall ist.
Aber so ein Random-Test-Tool für irgendwelche Manager wär auch nicht verkehrt.
Das könnte man denen einfach schicken, so ein Random-Link.
Wenn irgendein, was weiß ich, irgendein Manager hat einen YouTube-Talk gehört, dass Tests wichtig sind.
Und kommt dann, Jungs, wie hoch ist unsere Testabdeckung?
Und, äh, ihr denkt euch dann so, ja wie, ihr wolltet doch nie, dass wir Tests programmieren.
Also schicken wir einfach den Random-Link zum TestChamp.
Der Manager macht den TestChamp auf und sieht, aha, 78%.
78% Abdeckung, wunderbar.
Weiter geht's.
Was ich halt, ja, du hast, du, du, du hast schon recht.
Aber ich bin da wahrscheinlich auch nicht der richtige Typ für.
Ich krieg Anfälle, wenn das alles immer zu langsam geht.
Das, das, das stimmt schon.
Ich, ich geb dir ja auch vollkommen recht.
Gerade, sagen wir mal, irgendwie im medizinischen Bereich oder was weiß ich, Luftfahrt, Raumfahrt, äh, was auch immer, ja.
Ähm, ich, gibt's, gibt's bestimmt noch, gibt's bestimmt noch viel, viel, viel mehr, äh, Bereich, ja.
Insulin.
Äh, Mikrocontroller.
Mikrocontroller programmieren für irgendwelche Insulinpumpen oder sowas zum Beispiel.
Das ist was, da würde ich auch sagen, hey, das sollte man jetzt vielleicht nicht auf gut Glück losprogrammieren und dann das Ding mal als Update pushen und hoffen, dass alles noch funktioniert.
Das ist vielleicht nicht die beste Idee.
Und, na gut, Assistenzsysteme beim Auto, da kommt es ja öfters mal vor, dass die Leute nebenran fahren und dann nicht mal, also es kam ja in letzter Zeit schon öfters vor, dass die Leute nebenran fahren und dann erstmal mit ihrem Auto nicht mal weiterfahren können, weil es updaten muss.
Wenn du wüsstest, wie schlecht unsere Software ist, äh, ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
Du weißt ja nie, ob dein Test auch wirklich alles abdeckt.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten haben Tests für Tests.
Was ich jetzt schon ein paar, was ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gelesen habe, wo wir aber wirklich weit, weit davon entfernt sind, aber wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es im medizinischen Bereich und auch Luft-, Raumfahrt und sonst was, also da, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, dass es wirklich Leute gibt, die dafür eingestellt werden, Tests zu wenden.
Tests zu verifizieren.
Also das gibt es ja wirklich.
Es gibt wirklich, es gibt wirklich Unternehmen, die dann irgendwelche Mathematiker und Big-Brain-Leute einstellen, die verifizieren, also mit irgendwelchen, fragt mich nicht, mathematischen Theorien, die verifizieren, dass der Programmablauf nur quasi den Weg nehmen kann, der auch...
Wie soll ich das?
Nein, das ist falsch, weil ich nur gewollt habe, dass der Programmablauf keinen anderen Weg nehmen kann.
Das gibt es. Also Microsoft hat zum Beispiel sowas für Hyper-V gemacht angeblich.
Microsoft hat angeblich Kernfunktionen von Hyper-V von Mathematikern untersuchen lassen,
die mathematisch bewiesen haben, dass es keine Bugs gibt.
Keine Bugs ist natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich ausgedrückt,
dass es keine Abweichung vom vorgegebenen Programmablauf gibt.
Das heißt nicht, wenn in dieser Vorgabe ein Logik-Denkfehler ist, dass es da nicht auch Bugs geben kann.
Aber das ist klar, das funktioniert ja nicht.
Da wird es dann wahrscheinlich relativ teuer und advanced.
Miki, danke für den Sub.
Okay, wir müssen das Video jetzt mal fertig gucken.
Wir sind noch gar nicht durch. Ich habe wieder ewig geschwätzt für ein 5-Minuten-Video.
Ich muss schon wieder...
Weil ich es gerade im Chat lese.
Cloud. Ja, das stimmt. Es gibt immer noch einige, die ein No-Cloud-Policy haben.
Aber was bei uns jetzt lustig ist, da muss ich richtig kecken bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Also, sie haben vor ein paar Jahren...
Sie erzählten nach dem Motto, Cloud, Cloud, quasi Cloud-only.
Wir machen nichts mehr ohne Cloud.
Also, Cloud ist das einzig wahre.
Und jeder, der es wagt zu sagen, dass nicht Cloud, der wird ausgepeitscht, so nach dem Motto.
Also, das war so die Marschrichtung bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Und letztens, vor... ist doch gar nicht lang her, einem Monat oder so,
habe ich so gehört, ach ja, übrigens, No-Cloud, äh, nicht No-Cloud, übrigens hier Cloud,
Cloud-only und sonst was, ähm, das ist doch nicht so.
Also, unser Hauptsystem bleibt jetzt erstmal die nächsten fünf Jahre, kommt nicht in die Cloud.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Alter, warum macht ihr immer so eine Attacke
und rudert dann ein halbes Jahr später wieder zurück?
Das macht es alles nicht glaubwürdiger.
Kennt ihr das vielleicht auch, vielleicht von euch von der Arbeit,
dass oft mal, zumindest bei uns habe ich so den Eindruck,
es werden wöchentlich...
...neue Dinger verkündet und, und, äh, angepriesen,
von denen bestimmt 80% niemals wieder erwähnt werden.
Ja, zum Beispiel kommen dann so, ich denke mir jetzt mal ein bisschen was aus,
ja, da kommt dann so nach dem Motto, ihr dürft kein Ticket mehr annehmen ohne XY.
Oder, wenn ihr ein Ticket aufmacht, dann nur noch so und so.
Ihr müsst jetzt Zeiterfassung in System A, B, C und jetzt auch noch in System D machen.
Und bla bla bla, also irgendwelche Sachen.
Und das Beste, was man bei uns auf der Arbeit mittlerweile machen kann, ist Folgendes.
Wenn mal wieder sowas Großartiges verkündet wird, du wartest zwei Monate.
Du wartest zwei Monate.
Und von allem, also von, muss ich unbedingt sagen, von den meisten Sachen hörst du nie wieder was,
dann musst du sie auch nicht mehr machen.
Von den Dingern, die du nach zwei Monaten wieder hörst, die kannst du dann machen.
Also das Beste bei uns auf der Arbeit ist so eine...
Erstmal so Pendel ausweichen.
Erstmal so Pendel mäßig ausweichen.
Oh, da ist was Neues.
Eines von 30 Milliarden ganz ultra wichtig, hoch priorisierten, ganz wichtigen, wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Also wenn man 500 Sachen hat, die alle die wichtigsten Sachen sind, dann ist nichts mehr die wichtigste Sache.
Versteht ihr, wie ich meine?
Du kannst nicht zu allem sagen, höchste Priorität, das ist das Wichtigste oder sonst wie.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Es...
Weil dann, wenn du das so inflationär verwendest,
dein Chef schaut meine Streams, ja.
Ihr wisst jetzt aber nicht, was da dran irgendwie nicht stimmen sollte.
Dann hat das keinen Wert mehr.
Also sprich, wenn man zu allem immer sagt, das ist das Wichtigste oder das ist das Beste oder, keine Ahnung,
das ist das, worum jetzt höchste Priorität...
Dann ist nichts höchste Priorität.
Und das ist auch so eine Falle, da tappen wir auf der Arbeit öfters rein,
dass heute einer ankommt, ah, was weiß ich, Thema A, höchste Priorität, morgen ist irgendwas anderes jetzt Thema B, höchste Priorität.
Und wenn du dann fragst, ja, was ist denn jetzt mit Thema A, ähm, da sagt er, ja, äh, auch höchste Priorität.
Das ist ein bisschen wie, das ist ein bisschen wie Tickets.
Äh, wenn du Tickets bekommst, die sind ja aus Prinzip immer hoch oder sehr hoch.
Obwohl die überhaupt nicht hoch oder sehr hoch sind.
Das heißt, das klappt nicht, ja.
Deswegen ist das Beste, was man machen kann bei uns, erst einmal, gerade wenn so neue Sachen angekündigt werden,
erst einmal zwei Monate die Füße stillhalten und gucken, was davon ist denn noch da, ja.
Was, was, was ist denn, was ist denn noch?
Was, was, was ist denn noch, ja.
Und dann klappt das.
Die wichtigsten Mails sind ja auch immer mit wichtig, genau, genau.
Genau, weil ja auch nur wichtige Leute wichtige Mails schicken, ja.
Mein Chef weiß, dass das so ist bei uns.
Der hat ja oftmals selbst das Problem.
Wenn mein Chef mir was sagt, dass ich das machen soll, dann mach ich das.
Ja.
Dann muss ich sagen, ich, ich versuch mir dann, der kümmert sich ja auch um die Sachen, wenn, wenn, wenn ich was sage, wenn wir was sagen.
Deswegen versuche ich dann auch dementsprechend auch immer, mich da möglichst schnell drum zu kümmern, wenn der irgendwas kurzfristiges hat.
Aber der hat ja die gleichen Probleme.
Die kommen ja auch zu dem und sagen, sag deinen Jungs mal, die müssen jetzt ganz, ganz dringend, was weiß ich, noch Zeiterfassung in System C zusätzlich machen.
Nächste Woche heißt es dann wieder, ah ja, übrigens, jetzt doch nicht.
Oder hin und her, der hat ja genau das gleiche Problem.
Denn ich gehe davon aus, dass der das.
Genauso handhabt, das bloß nicht an die große Glocke hängt.
So, jetzt gucken wir jetzt aber endlich mal, fertig.
Also.
Customer.
Ah je.
Also Endkundenkontakt ist was, das vermeide ich erfolgreich seit über zehn Jahren.
Das Problem ist, dass der Customer.
Je nachdem, was er mit dem auswählen teilweise nicht, weil er weiß das selbst nicht, was er eigentlich haben will.
Stakeholder.
And it's not like a blueprint for constructing a building.
These requirements are very likely to change multiple times throughout the project for non technical people.
Software development seems like black magic and it's very important for you, the developer, to communicate when you recognize something as a bad idea or something that's going to take a ton of time to Informatiker im Chat.
Das haben wir auch schon durch.
Lustig, dass du das schreibst.
Wir wechseln jetzt von Zeitschätzung auf Komplexität, aber nicht auf Story Point, sondern T-Shirt-Kurse.
Ja, ja, das haben wir auch schon durch.
Das war auch mal eine Sache.
Da sollten wir T-Shirt, das hatten wir, witzig, dass du das schreibst, genau das gleiche hatten wir auch schon.
Mittlerweile machen wir das nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile machen wir keine T-Shirt-Kurse mehr.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile schreiben wir wieder irgendwelche Zeiten dran.
Allerdings sind die Zeitschätzungen bei uns immer ziemlich, ziemlich vage.
Ja, du sagst dann so nach dem Motto.
Ja, Alter, ich weiß doch überhaupt nicht, was ihr von mir wollt.
Wie soll ich denn schätzen, was da, wie lang das dauert?
Und dann kommt man so als Antwort so nach dem Motto.
Ja, schätze mal irgendwas.
Und das mache ich mittlerweile.
Ich schätze einfach irgendwas.
Und oftmals ist es dann so, dass dann irgendeiner kommt und sagt.
Ah, nee, das können wir ja nicht machen.
Das dauert ja so lang.
Es ist so wir.
Es ist einfach so wir.
So, jetzt muss ich auch wirklich fertig gucken.
Ich unterbreche jetzt nicht, bis das Video fertig ist.
...to communicate when you recognize something as a bad idea.
...or something that's going to take a ton of time to refactor.
When I first started doing freelance work,
I took the approach that the customer was always right
and ended up working many hours for free just to make the customer happy.
And I really only blame myself,
because it's my fault for not being a good enough communicator.
But in some cases, you may end up with a very difficult client.
And for that reason, I generally recommend people do their billing on an hourly rate
as opposed to a lump sum for an entire project,
because it's more transparent and allows for a clean break if things go really south.
I want a divorce.
Divorce?
I knew we had something in common.
Here, sign these.
And with that...
Divorce?
Da muss ich immer an den Typ denken.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie heißt...
Amy Jo, I want divorce.
Wisst ihr, wen ich meine?
Ihr kennt das 100 pro.
We've reached the final opinion.
Most comments in code are in fact a pernicious form of code duplication.
Or on a related note, readability...
Oh, oh, das ist genau das, was ich...
Ich glaube, der sagt jetzt genau das Gleiche, was ich eben auch als Beispiel genannt habe.
Ich glaube, dass ich das genau genommen habe.
Mit that, we've reached the final opinion.
Most comments in code are in fact a pernicious form of code duplication.
Or on a related note, readability is the most important aspect of your code.
For the most part, I agree with these opinions.
I think writing code...
Man kann nicht Ja oder Nein sagen.
Ja, readability ist, würde ich sagen, in den meisten Fällen schon eines der wichtigsten Sachen.
Aber...
Aber es kann durchaus Fälle geben, wo das nicht so ist.
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, hier, das hier muss bis auf den letzten CPU-Cycle optimiert sein,
dann ist das halt vielleicht nicht mehr readable.
Oder es war noch nicht gut readable.
I agree with these opinions.
I think writing code that is simple and self-describing is the ultimate goal we should strive for.
The reality, though, is that even if you write perfectly readable code,
I might be able to tell what it's doing, but not why it's there in the first place.
Comments that explain why something exists...
Das ist das, was ich ja vorhin auch gemeint habe.
Genau.
Richtig.
Kommt auch noch dabei.
Nein, aber ganz im Ernst.
Ganz im Ernst.
Also jetzt mal.
Jetzt mal.
Jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz.
Was ist besser lesbar?
Okay, das ist auch ein doofes Beispiel.
Es gibt ja auch eine For-Each-Schleife mittlerweile in JavaScript.
Also ich persönlich mag ja die traditionelle Loop-Geschichte lieber,
als die Loop mit irgendwelchen Lambda-Dingern hintendran.
Gerade nachdem ja mittlerweile JavaScript auch sowas wie ein richtiges For-Each hat.
Dann ist mir das da unten aber jetzt vielleicht nicht als Zählen, wir zählen, sondern als For-Each.
Also als ausgeschriebenes For-Each ist mir das lieber als das.
Mit einer Situation wie dieser beginne ich mit dem Buchstaben, den ich am besten lesen kann.
Und wenn die Leistung tatsächlich ein Problem wird, dann kann ich es in der Zukunft optimieren.
Aber 90% der Zeit ist es zu unsignifizierbar.
Nein, nicht das Chat.
Niemals das For-Each.
For-Each.
So, JavaScript hat doch jetzt For-
Wie heißt das?
For-Each-Off oder sowas.
Oder war das C++?
Bringe ich das jetzt gerade durcheinander?
Ne, ne, JavaScript hat doch auch sowas.
Achso, meine Suche ist ja kaputt.
For-Off ist es.
For-Off.
Ja, ja, genau, genau.
Hier, das da.
Also.
Okay.
Was?
Was besser?
Hier.
Was weiß ich?
Und jetzt fange ich schon mit Notepad an.
Ich muss Notepad machen, weil ich kann Visual Studio Code nicht aufmachen, weil ich keine Suche habe.
So, also.
Das da.
Lolwe.
Was auch immer.
Oder das da.
Also ich persönlich bin ja für das da.
Ich bin ja für...
Vote.
Okay, okay.
Äh.
Moment.
Wir machen eine Umfrage.
Alles klar.
Machen wir.
Äh, aus.
Kaputt.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ah ja, hier.
Ja, das kann man jetzt.
Das kann man jetzt schlecht hier rein copy-pasten.
So, Umfrage.
Zack.
Beste Umfrage.
Was?
Ähm.
Ich hab die Hälfte nicht mitkopiert, Alter.
Ja.
Ich hab die Hälfte nicht mitkopiert.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, ja.
Also ich persönlich bin für das.
Es mag alles auch sein.
Ich kann eine Daseinsberechtigung haben.
Es ist auf jeden Fall Geschmackssache.
Zum Beispiel lasst du hier keinen Break drin machen.
Na doch, du kannst einen Break machen.
Kannst Return machen.
Kommt das Gleiche raus.
Die wichtige Frage ist doch Range-Based Loop vs. Normal.
Äh.
Eigentlich, wenn ich keinen Index brauche, immer, immer for each.
Das stimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist, das ist richtig.
Ja.
Wenn du, wenn du es vorher noch filtern willst.
Äh.
Umtransformieren und dann for each machen, ist es vielleicht sinnvoll.
Wobei man das da, das da, könnte man genau so, könnte man auch da reinschreiben.
Ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so schön, aber.
Ich mein.
Ansonsten hast du halt das Problem.
Äh, Moment.
Das da sollte man vielleicht weglassen, weglassen so hier.
Äh.
Ansonsten hast du halt das Problem, dass, äh, was weiß ich.
Dass du dann hier noch irgendwelche Dinger dazwischen machst.
So, bla, bla, bla.
Das macht's dann auch nicht gerade übersichtlich.
Ist, ist Geschmacksware.
Ja.
Gut.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben.
Mach's mal wieder dicht.
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up there.
Don't forget to hit the like button and make sure to leave your own controversial opinion in the comments below.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Was hältst du davon?
Okay.
Von.
Was?
Function on returning closure.
Okay.
Ja.
Äh.
Wieso?
Was soll ich davon?
Also, das da finde ich vielleicht ein bisschen schwer.
Das hier finde ich recht eindeutig.
Wobei.
Ja, gut.
Das kann man machen.
Warum nicht?
Sonderlich, sag mal so, sonderlich lesbar mag's jetzt vielleicht nicht sein.
Schau rechts.
Ach so.
Das ist mir zu hoch jetzt.
Big, big brain.
Zu.
Zu low IQ-Zeit heute Morgen.
Ja, das geht jetzt nicht.
12.46 Uhr.
Oh, das fällt mir ein.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss gleich was essen.
Aber wir gucken jetzt noch ein paar Witz.
Was ist das?
PlayStation 4 Emulation auf dem PC ist da.
Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Ich mein, PS4 auf dem PC emulieren ist ja an sich schon eigentlich ein bisschen der Witz.
Na?
Weil die PS4 ist ein PC.
Das ist ganz stinknormale x86 Hardware.
Oder x86-64 Hardware.
Piko, dankeschön für den Sub.
Sechs Monate.
Huge Subscriptions hier.
Oh ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Das ist das Gleiche.
Das muss ich jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz was zu sagen.
Ja, das ist das Gleiche, wie wenn du viel Link verwendest in C-Sharp.
Das durchläuft auch gerne mehrfach alles.
Ja.
Da muss man aufpassen.
Generell sind diese so ein bisschen funktional angehauten Sachen, die man nicht so gut kennt,
die man nicht so gut kennt, die man nicht so gut kennt, die man nicht so gut kennt, die man nicht so gut kennt,
die man nicht so gut kennt.
Die sind vielleicht, wenn man sie falsch verwendet oftmals, ziemlich lahm.
Gucken wir mal.
PS4 Emulation.
Ganz dumm Schwätzer.
Das sind die Hersteller vielleicht.
Na, ich lad' mir ja auch keine ROMs runter.
Ich hab' ja alle meine ROMs selbstverständlich selbst gerippt von original physischen Datenträgern.
Ihr bestimmt auch.
Äh...
Manche Sachen würden überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Die ganze beispielsweise, ich weiß nicht, ob einer von euch vielleicht ein bisschen A Link to the Past Randomizer guckt,
das würde überhaupt nicht funktionieren ohne Emulation.
Es gibt ja auch nicht so viel Grund aktuell, das auf dem PC zu emulieren.
Der PS4 kostet nicht viel, PS4 kriegst du noch überall und es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Spiele, würde ich sagen, die man unbedingt haben will, die exklusiv sind.
Also die letzte Konsolengeneration.
Ist ja quasi die Konsolengeneration, wo die Exklusivität ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist.
Zu Xbox 360 und PS3 Zeiten war viel, viel mehr, ich kann es euch leider nicht belegen, vielleicht erzähle ich Scheiß, ja,
aber gefühlt zumindest ist das so, dass viel, viel mehr Sachen damals noch konsolenexklusiv waren, was heute auch auf dem PC kommt.
Spine, a Playstation 4 Emulator for the PC that was just released to the public.
Now, while still very early in its infancy, it can indeed boot and play some Playstation 4 commercial games.
Now, while you shouldn't expect Ghost of Tsushima or Bloodborne anytime soon, this is a massive step forward for PS4 emulation and it will continue to grow in advance from here on out.
Oh, nice PS4 Spiel.
And let me tell you, it's got me pretty excited.
Now, before we jump into Spine.
Gar so Sachen wie, wie, ach, wie hieß das, der DHL Simulator, Death Stranding, genau, sind ja mittlerweile auch auf dem PC am Start.
Excited.
I wanted to mention that if you google PS4 Emulation, and I just did this just before, the first hit that you get is a website known as PCSX4.
Bestimmt, bestimmt, ich hätte es gesagt.
This looks legitimate, and if you remember, PCSX is a popular Playstation 1 Emulator.
Now, PCSX4 even has a Github link, and everything looks official like this is a legit emulator.
Now, I want to be very clear, this is all fake.
Do not click on that download link for this, because honestly, who knows what you're downloading.
But I just felt like it's my duty to tell you and let everyone know that you should not download PCSX4.
It's simply not real.
I'm not really sure the purpose of this.
But there is no way PS4 Emulation is this far advanced.
Debated.
Where first party Sony titles are running flawlessly under emulation on a PC.
It's just not real.
But let's go back to Spine and talk about that.
So, it's the work of an anonymous developer known as SpineDev, and it's been in development for quite a few years.
In fact, going back to 2019, it was booting into commercial games.
So, the progress that we're going to see today isn't necessarily new.
It's just that SpineDev, as he's known, has finally released.
He's emulated to the public and released a compatibility sheet that really illustrates what's actually playable.
Now, back in 2019, SpineDev released a YouTube video showing some of the progress,
and it was booting and running games like the Mega Man Legacy Collection and Stardew Valley.
Jawoll!
Ich kann jetzt NES Games, die auf der PS4 nochmal neu erschienen sind,
kann ich jetzt per Emulation auf dem PC...
What the fuck?
... aber es war ein ziemlich guter Start.
Also, warum bringe ich heute Spine?
Nun, der öffentliche Update wurde gerade gelistet, der die Kompatibilitätsliste, die ich erwähnt habe, eingeführt hat.
Und es liegt an rund 50 oder so Titeln, die man im Spiel bekommen kann und die man bemerkt, dass sie ein bisschen spielbar sind.
Und viele andere, die man in den Intro-Screen booten kann, bevor sie crashen.
Und es gibt einige YouTube-Videos, die schon da sind, die die Potenzial- und was man mit dem Spiel sehen kann.
Aber wie immer...
... weiß PS4.
... kann man sich das mal anschauen.
Nun, die Ergebnisse sind ziemlich primitiv, aber sie sind sehr versprochen.
Und man sollte sich daran erinnern, dass das sehr viel Arbeit im Prozess ist.
Und man sollte definitiv nichts von AAA zu tun erwarten.
Sag mal, warum zeigt ihr denn die ganze Zeit Sonic beim PS4?
Haben die das nochmal released auf der PS4 oder wie?
Oder was?
Ach nee, das ist Dings.
Ist das Generations?
Also, ich blick bei den Sonic-Spielen nicht mal durch.
Da habe ich absolut keinen Überblick.
Was bei Sonic-Sachen angeht.
Was mich bei Sonic ja noch viel mehr verwirrt, ist, ähm, wie soll ich sagen, die, ähm, Sonic-Custom-Character, weiß gar nicht, wie man das jetzt genau nennt, Community.
Also, das ist teilweise höchst verstörend, was ich da gesehen habe schon.
... limited pretty much to mostly 2D-Indie-Games, and they seem to run pretty well for the most part.
The emulator comes with that compatibility.
The compatibility guide, as mentioned, and it's just an Excel-Spreadsheet, and if you look through this list, you'll basically get an idea of what's playable, and again, most of these games tend to be 2D-Indie-based games, but there are a couple of AAA-Games.
Ich meine, geil, kann ich ein re-releasedes NES-Game im PS4-Emulator spielen, was schlechter aussieht als im NES-Emulator?
Okay, aber ich will es jetzt nicht schlecht machen, weil das ist natürlich, wie sagt man so schön, Basic-Sachen.
Also, also, ähm...
... Pionier-Arbeit oder, ja, Grundlage-, Grundlagenforschung, könnte man sagen, was PS4-Emulation angeht.
Daraus kann natürlich noch mehr werden.
... AAA-Games that are considered in-game here, and I'm gonna go ahead and take a look at one of these AAA-Games and see if it actually works for us.
Now, setting up Spine is pretty complicated.
Muss selbst kompilieren unter Linux, ja?
... I have to mention to you guys that it runs exclusively under Linux.
Ja, sehr gute Idee.
There is no Windows executable for this, and honestly, I'm not sure if there ever will be one.
So, what I ended up doing was installing a Linux distribution on an external SSD, and I'm gonna connect it up to my laptop here that's running an Nvidia 2060 and has an Intel i7-Processor.
Now, as mentioned, there is no Windows-Build, and you have to use Linux, and if you decide that you wanna use...
... äh, About Stronic, das mit Wine ist umgedreht. Das ist für Windows-Unternehmen.
Das ist für Windows unter Linux und nicht für Linux unter Windows.
Du meinst per WSL vielleicht, ja?
... a virtual machine, then you need to make sure that your GPU pass-through is active, otherwise I don't think this emulator will work.
For me, I didn't wanna mess with VMs, I tried VMWare, but I didn't get very far getting the GPU pass-through working properly.
So in the end, I just installed a native Linux onto my external SSD and plugged it into my laptop, and that works totally fine.
Once you've set up Linux and downloaded Spine, simply extract it to a folder, and this is the complicated part.
Hört sich, hört sich, hört sich etwas holprig an zu installieren.
You need to pull PlayStation 4 firmware files.
Now the problem is, you can't just download a PS4 firmware.
Das ist ja wie, das ist wie beim PS1-Emulator, wo du dir bis heute noch aus dubiosen Quellen BIOS-Sachen runterladen musst.
... update file like you could with RPCS3, so you'll need to access a hacked or modified PS4...
... to pull down decrypted firmware data off of that hacked PS4...
... and then copy it into a firmware folder on Spine...
... and now you should all be set up to run this emulator.
But of course, you still need some games, so how do you get games over?
Well, I took a look at the compatibility list, and I took a look at all the games that I've purchased over the years...
Okay, das dürfte für 99% der Weltbevölkerung nicht machbar sein.
... PS4, and once again, you can't just...
... you can't just transfer over PS4-Package-Files that you download or anything.
They need to be installed on a hacked PS4, and the contents of that package is what Spine is expecting.
In other words...
What the fuck?
... an eBoot.bin is the executable that it's looking for to launch the game.
So what I ended up doing was installing packages onto my hacked PS4 of games that I own, and then FTP...
Na ja, dass das unter Linux only läuft, ist vielleicht gar nicht so abwegig.
Ich mein...
... die...
für irgendwelche PS4-Geschichten.
Deswegen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass es niemals richtig unter Windows laufen wird.
KVM, QEMO ist halt lahm.
Im Vergleich zu, sag mal,
zu dem Wine-Ansatz.
Außerdem Wine,
Wine, KVM ist für unterschiedliche
CPU-Architektur.
Äh, nee, nicht,
was laber ich denn? QEMO.
QEMO ist für unterschiedliche CPU-Architektur.
Das brauchst du ja nicht.
Das ist ja das Gleiche in deinem PC wie in der PS4.
Ähm,
na gut, du könntest ein KVM
laufen lassen mit
irgendeinem BSD drin.
Das wird es aber wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich wird es es auch nicht einfacher machen,
als irgendein Custom-Layer für Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert. Kein Schimmer.
Ich kann jetzt auch nur raten.
PS4-Docker, genau.
Deine Meinung zu WSL.
Ja, notwendiges,
ich will nicht sagen übel, aber notwendige
Sache, weil viele Sachen unter Windows sind halt
einfach nicht gescheit benutzbar.
Daily-mäßig. Wenn man nicht
gerade ganz Hardcore-Windows
verdorben ist
schon. Deswegen ist
WSL notwendig.
Ich persönlich bevorzuge immer noch komplette
Linux-Installationen.
Oder aber, so wie hier,
Linux in der VM und Windows auf dem
Host.
On Spine.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine einfache Art,
dass jemand mir sagen wird, dass ich es hätte
getan können, aber das ist die Art, wie es für mich funktioniert.
Aber in jedem Fall, wenn du ein paar Spiele
aufgebaut hast, ist es jetzt wirklich ein Fall,
um in das Spiel zu starten.
Nun, das ist nicht sehr userfreundlich,
aber es soll nicht sein.
Dieser Emulator ist sehr früh im Entwicklung.
Es gibt keine GUI oder keine UI.
Und es gibt viele Hubs, die du durchführen musst.
Ja, und Garfisch. Garfisch ist aus.
Wenn du nicht Zugang zu einem modded PS4 hast,
dann kommst du nicht sehr weit.
Also, wir testen ein paar Spiele.
Nun, welche Spiele habe ich getestet?
Und wie funktionieren sie?
Nun, das erste Spiel, das ich getestet habe,
war Dead Cells.
Und ich muss sagen, das war eine großartige
erste Vorstellung, weil es sehr schnell
in den Titelscreen gedreht wurde.
Und das Spiel selbst ist ziemlich spielbar.
Aber natürlich wirst du die grafischen Probleme nicht kennen,
die sind ziemlich spielbar.
Dir wird schlecht, wenn du spielst, aber ...
Die Geschwindigkeit und die Leistung, die auf meinem
dreijährigen Laptop läuft, ist sehr beeindruckend.
Und nicht zu erwähnen, dass die Sound-Emulation
wirklich exzellent ist.
Nun, du kannst sehen, dass dieser Emulator
viel Aufmerksamkeit und Aufmerksamkeit
darin hat.
Und wiederum,
das ist ein ziemlich guter Start.
Nun, ich habe auch Sonic Mania getestet.
Nun, ich habe ein Video von Sonic Mania gesehen,
und es sah exzellent aus,
wenn man es auf Vollgeschwindigkeit runnt,
obwohl es mit Colour Palette ...
Das ist witzig, dass du es im Chat schreibst.
Das dachte ich auch die ganze Zeit,
aber es ist nicht so.
Eigentlich müsste es Linux Subsystem
vor Windows heißen.
Das dachte ich auch immer,
aber ist es eigentlich nicht.
Das, was das implementiert, ist,
dass ein Subsystem,
ein Windows Subsystem
für Linux,
um Linux
darauf laufen zu lassen.
Das ergibt schon Sinn.
Ich dachte aber am Anfang auch immer,
dass es so rum sein müsste.
Eigentlich klingt logischer.
Ist es aber im Endeffekt nicht.
Wo war man denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben?
Was hat er denn mit Subsonics Zeug?
... Issues, of course,
but I couldn't get over
how fast the emulation
is running in this instance.
With a few fixes,
Sonic Mania could be near perfect.
Now, of course,
the game is not going to tax
the CPU or GPU,
but it's a great early look
at the emulation
and its future potential.
Now, the next thing that I tried
was to up the ante
and look at a AAA game
on that list
and one of them was
Dark Souls Remastered.
Okay, lass mich raten.
Menü startet, danach Crash.
This game is not going to run.
I'm not really sure
why it would say in-game,
but it was on the list anyway.
So much to my surprise,
when I tried out
Dark Souls Remastered,
it loaded into the title screen
and it allowed me to enter the menu
and create a character.
And it even loads
into the intro sequence,
which I think is just video,
video files or bing files.
It has to be.
I don't think this is real time 3D.
And at the end of the intro sequence,
it actually got in-game.
And as you can see,
the emulation has not locked up.
You can still press your button inputs.
Now I want to tell you,
that's fine.
In-game ist vielleicht
also sehr wohlwollend ausgedrückt.
Currently closed source
and it may always be closed source.
This is the author's wishes,
which I totally respect.
They don't
want forks of the emulator
appearing and diluting.
Ich glaube, PS3 Emulation
funktioniert bis heute nicht.
But at the same time
ist aber auch ein schwieriges Thema.
Also ich glaube, eine PS4 lauffähig
zu machen auf dem PC
ist einfacher als eine PS3.
Echt gibt es jetzt?
Wie haben die das denn gemacht?
I'd love to get a close
look at this thing and see how it works.
Also Architektur mäßig
ist eine PS4 deutlich, deutlich
näher am PC dran als eine PS3.
Maybe we will get a write up
document on how it's all
been architected.
The PlayStation 4 although is
an x86 based game console
has quite a bit of complexity
associated with it.
For example, there are two pools
of memory in the PS4 architecture
known as garlic and onion.
I know they're weird
and interesting names,
but that's what they're called.
And emulating those memory pools
sounds extremely complicated to me.
And I'd love to learn more
about how that all works.
The other thing is the PS4 doesn't use
OpenGL, Vulkan or DirectX.
It has its own proprietary
graphics API known as GNM.
Now, Spine appears to be using
OpenGL as its renderer.
So even this would be a challenge
to overcome.
How does the OpenGL to GNM
kind of layer work?
How does that map across?
Am I even thinking about this
in the right way?
And I'm also curious about Shaders.
Keine Ahnung was er mir mitteilen möchte.
In any case, let's kind of move on now.
Looking at the R emulation subreddit,
SpineDev is actually quite active on there
and mentions that updates
should be more frequent
as there are significant improvements made,
which is kind of cool.
I mean, there's no reason just to,
you know, release an update next week
to fix a couple of minor things.
Massive.
I think the goal of this is
any time there is a breakthrough
in the emulation, they will...
Aber wisst ihr, was ich ganz cool finde
daran jetzt?
Ich glaube, mit sowas,
gerade durch Grafiken,
irgendwelche Glitches oder sonst wie,
bekommt man einen ganz guten Eindruck
da drüben,
da drüben, da drüben, da drüben, da drüben, da drüben.
Aber wie manche Games in turn funktionieren.
Für PS4-Emulationen ist es definitiv
ein Meilenstein und ein Breakthrough.
Und ich freue mich darauf, was da noch kommt.
Es wird auch andere Teams motivieren,
die auf PS4-Emulationen arbeiten,
um vielleicht zu verbessern
und vielleicht einander zu helfen.
Und das kann nur eine gute Sache
für die Gemeinschaft sein.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das die Hitboxen sind,
die man hier sieht.
Das sind einfach die Transparenz,
die nicht funktioniert.
Die Transparenz funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das hier die Hitbox...
Ich meine, das mag zufälligerweise
mit der Hitbox
übereinstimmen.
Das ist einfach
irgendwelche Transparenz-Effekte,
die nicht richtig funktionieren.
Also wir sehen,
dass wir nicht viel sehen,
dass es eigentlich
nicht richtig funktioniert.
Aber es hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert,
weil ich habe da vorher
noch nie was von gehört.
Was haben wir denn sonst jetzt hier noch?
Battlefield 2042 vs.
Bad Company 2 vs.
Battlefield 3 Early Graphics Comparsion.
Was willst du da?
Was willst du da groß...
Compartern?
Geh jetzt mal her.
Ich habe den
B kons beforehand and
battlefield 3 sieht echt noch
gut brauchbar aus.
Du siehst schon, dass das alt ist,
Aber das sieht schon okay aus.
Übrigens, das C4 fliegt überhaupt nicht richtig.
Das C4 in Bad Company 2 konntest du mit springen und nach oben,
konntest du bis dahinten, also du konntest in Bad Company 2
ohne Probleme, wenn hier hinten was stand, dann C4 hinschmeißen
mit Anlauf und springen und Maus hoch und sowas.
Das C4 ist ewig weit geflogen in Bad Company 2.
Also du siehst schon, gerade auch bei den Partikeleffekten
und so, du siehst schon das Alter.
Ja, doch, doch, das siehst du schon.
Es ist schon ein ziemlicher Unterschied.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass Bad Company 2 schlecht aussieht oder so.
Es sieht durchaus brauchbar aus.
Gut, da kannst du jetzt nicht allzu viel dabei ausmachen.
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch nur mal den Boden angucken.
Guckt euch mal den Boden an.
Den Boden hier an und allein auch hier, dass das nach Rinnen aussieht.
Also, man sieht schon das Alter.
Aber es sieht wirklich, das sieht echt in Ordnung aus.
So, jetzt brauchen wir noch Battlefield 3.
Comparison, wie auch immer das richtig heißt.
Ah, Caspian Border.
Gut, da muss ich euch jetzt sagen,
ist wirklich nicht viel Unterschied zwischen dem
und Battlefield.
Also, da ist jetzt wirklich nicht viel Unterschied.
Wobei man halt aber auch sagen muss,
gerade durch die Kompression
und hier so starke Vegetation
sieht das unter YouTube nicht so geil aus.
Ja, das sieht doch, doch, das sieht jetzt schon besser aus.
Ja, ja.
Also, die Bäume sind deutlich detaillierter.
Und mehr.
Aber so ein großer Unterschied ist es nicht.
Die Felsen sehen genauso aus,
eckig wie in Battlefield 3.
Aber gut, es ist ja wahrscheinlich auch mehr oder weniger Import aus Battlefield 3.
Guck dir mal, so ein großer Unterschied ist es nicht.
Es ist halt, es ist halt dieser, dieser grau-blau-matte Look von Battlefield 3.
Was, was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Guckt mal die Minimap.
Lull.
Da siehst du ja gar nichts mehr drauf.
Also, da muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen, ist der Unterschied.
Eher subtil, ja.
Was denkst du wegen der Verschiebung?
Ich habe, ich habe, okay, das sieht natürlich deutlich besser aus in Battlefield 2042,
die Waffenmodels.
Ähm, ich bin der Meinung, mir ist es lieber,
das Game kommt in einem brauchbaren Zustand raus.
Zumal wir eh das gleiche kriegen.
Ja, hätten die jetzt released, hätten wir dann quasi,
also den Stand, den wir dann zu Release bekommen,
ist der Stand, den wir jetzt bekommen hätten,
mit Day One Patch und 1, 2 großen Patches.
Also, mir ist es lieber, das kommt spielbarer raus.
Ja, der Beleuchtung, ja,
das stimmt schon, Beleuchtung ist ein großer Unterschied.
Aber das kann man, finde ich, immer recht schwer beurteilen,
weil Battlefield halt 3 diesen, diesen komischen,
diesen matten, grau-blauen Filter drüber hat.
Das sieht, das sieht Tageslicht, in Battlefield 3 sieht halt
nicht so richtig tageslichtmäßig aus.
Je nachdem, was die machen, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es,
dass die Verspätung deutlich zur Spielbarkeit beitragen kann.
Moment, man konnte das Ding umschießen in Battlefield 3, ging das?
Das war mir so gar nicht bewusst.
Das ist doch nicht der große Mast.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das umschießen kann.
Oder sind es die Reste vom großen Mast?
Ja gut, also die Beleuchtung ist halt hier unterhalb der Filter.
Hier sieht halt grün, wirklich grün aus.
Ja, aber ansonsten, also die Unterschiede,
die Waffenmodels sind halt viel, viel besser.
Das sieht man sofort, ja.
Aber ansonsten ist das doch schon jetzt,
es ist recht, recht subtil.
Ja, die Bäume sehen natürlich auch viel, viel,
viel fülliger aus, irgendwie als die komischen Dinger hier in Battlefield 3.
Aber Welten sind das nicht.
Aber sind die Disc-Versionen nicht schon lange gepresst?
Das mag schon sein, aber die Disc-Versionen bringen dir ja nichts,
weil du es nicht spielen kannst.
Selbst wenn du jetzt irgendwie, also erstens, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
und zweitens, wenn das so ist, musst du eh erstmal 200 GB der One-Patch runterladen,
wenn du das Spiel das erste Mal startest.
Also es ist egal, was auf der Disc drauf ist.
Falls es überhaupt schon Discs gibt.
Tribulon, Dankeschön, 22 Monate Subscription.
Grafik wird runtergeschraubt, dass man viel FPS hat, korrekt.
Werde ich auch so machen.
Das war ja lustig, ne.
EA hat mich ja angeschrieben wegen Spiel-Playtest und so.
Und das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Und die haben gesagt, ich kann das, ich brauche einen anderen PC,
weil ich eine 1080 Ti habe.
Und die Mindestanforderung wäre eine 2060.
Ich habe gesagt, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Meine Grafikkarte ist doppelt, ist 50, 60 Prozent schneller als eine 2060.
Das wird nicht RTX OLED, garantiert nicht.
Muss ja auch auf AMD-Karten laufen.
Ja gut, hier ist der Unterschied jetzt schon,
also gerade von der Vegetation ist der Unterschied schon deutlich sichtbar,
dass es viel detaillierter ist in Battlefield 2042.
Aber Battlefield 3 sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Es wird keine Disks mehr geben.
Ja, aber PS4 und PS5-Versionen, das muss doch eine Disc sein da drin.
Da hast du nicht so viel Speicher wie auf dem PC.
Disc ist nur Download, auch auf der PlayStation, das wäre ein ziemlicher Fail.
Man musste erst mal die Hälfte einer Platte dafür opfern.
Battlefield Mobile, was?
Was ist Battlefield Mobile?
Was ist?
Ist das irgendein Battlefield 3 Reset?
Ist das ein D-Skin fürs Handy, oder was?
Für die China-Chinesen?
Das sieht voll, das sieht original aus wie Battlefield 3,
auch vom Logo her und so.
Also vom Style her.
Okay, das ist, das ist Bazaar, nur in schlecht.
Bazaar in schlecht, mit Fahrzeugen.
Na gut, Conquest.
Es ist, es ist, das ist Battlefield 3, oder?
Es ist Battlefield 3 für...
Mobile.
Fuck, warum?
Na gut, weil es Geld bringt, was ist das für eine Frage?
Weil es Geld bringt, was sonst, ja?
Ist ja klar.
How to Google it.
Okay, das gucken wir, Leute.
4,60, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an.
Oh Leute, Moment, das muss ich, das muss ich euch zeigen.
Ich will mir das Video nicht angucken.
Ich wollte euch das bloß mal zeigen, weil das wurde mir letztens,
das wurde mir letztens vorgeschlagen auf dem, auf dem Tablet abends,
als ich, als ich noch ein bisschen Streams geguckt habe.
Alter.
Das ist, das ist die, also wenn einer Let's Play,
das ist wie ein hyperaktiver Let's Player nur auf der Kommandozeile.
Sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich kann mir das keine 10 Minuten angucken.
Aber es ist, es, es, es hat was.
Es hat was.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I have this problem, okay?
Okay, I have several problems, but my...
Es ist ohne Scheiß, es ist hyper, hyperaktiver Let's Player auf Command Line.
...primary problem today.
...is that I hate using Cheat Sheet.
Not because Cheat Sheet's bad,
but because I just have a sucky workflow.
Like, when I wanna do it, you know what I do?
Das ist so, das ist so wie irgendein, irgendein so eine Let's Play,
so eine YouTube Let's Play Persönlichkeit,
die sie irgendwie funny, äh, Garry's Mod oder, äh, Zeug früher gemacht hat,
jetzt bloß auf Command Line, ja?
Total, total wirres Zeug, äh.
Open up a new terminal, I go in here and I curl Cheat Sheet...
The fuck?
...and then I have to leave the terminal and jump back,
or I create a new TMUX window and then I jump in here and then that's...
Das ist, das ist quasi wie, das ist XQC auf der Kommandozeile.
...where I do my little curl and do that and then it shows up, okay?
And then I have to jump back, oh, oh, I gotta go back to one this time.
The fuck?
...and then I have this, like, this window...
Was bin ich sehend?
...that's just hanging out there. I don't want that window hanging out there.
That sucks. No, I don't want that. So we're gonna fix that, okay?
Das könnte der von Netflix sein, ja, ich guck das, ich guck das.
Das wird, das wird später noch schlimmer.
...separate answers.
Leute, das wird, das wird später, das wird später noch schlimmer.
Now we need a little TMUX shortcut for this to work out, okay?
Guckt euch mal die Tastatur an, Alter.
Das ist so Hipster-Style, keine Ahnung, ey.
Let's open up the, my TMUX config, let's go in here and let's go bind key dash R I,
I don't need I, okay? I already know what I is, which I can't even remember what it is,
because it's useless, okay?
And now...
Oh man.
...
Ich will mir das nicht angucken, ich, ich war bloß echt, ich, ich war bloß echt voll überrascht.
Das ist quasi, quasi so ein hyperaktiver Let's Play Livestreamer, nur im Terminal.
Das fand ich echt heftig, dass es sowas gibt, aber ich kann's verstehen, warum nicht?
Und in gewisser Weise finden das sicherlich viele Entertain, Entertainent.
Der ist immer so, ja, ja, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass das gefakt ist oder macht das so.
Ich kann's mir bloß nicht, ich kann's mir bloß nicht lange angucken.
Ökonomische Tastatur.
Ich weiß nicht, ich komm mit sowas nicht klar.
Ich brauch ne stinknormale Tastatur.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns noch mal was wirklich Gutes an.
Jetzt gucken wir uns noch ein gutes Video an, das kenn ich schon.
Äh, also das hab ich schon mal im Vorfeld geguckt, aber das ist wirklich nice.
Da erfährt man vieles, was man noch nicht über Google wusste.
Also, die Suchmaschine, nicht über die Firma.
When you first start learning to code, you might feel guilty for using Google to figure out how to do simple things.
But after ten years of experience, you'll be so skilled at suppressing your guilt that you just won't feel bad for cheating anymore.
Some people say a software engineer is just a professional Google searcher.
And that's 100% true.
10x developers are smart enough to know that memorizing syntax, algorithms and data types can be a waste of time.
It's more efficient to just Google the information you need on demand.
But Googling it is an art form.
And in this video, we'll look at 10 tips to Google stuff like a 10x developer.
Du kannst auch DuckDuckGo benutzen.
Das muss kein Google sein.
What usually happens is you're coding along and then some crazy error message pops up and ruins your day.
You copy the message, paste it into Google.
And what you find is that developers have been Googling the same error message for hundreds of years.
And it overlaps across multiple frameworks and programming languages.
One easy way to refine your search is to simply wrap it in quotes.
That tells Google to search for an exact match, when normally it does a more fuzzy match.
Das kennen wir, glaube ich, alle noch, dass du Google quoten kannst.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Trick.
Man kann da noch einen Plus davor machen.
Dann ist es wirklich ganz exakt das.
For synonyms and related terms.
Because in many cases, you're looking for that one lucky person that had that same weird error,
who was brave enough to post it on Stack Overflow.
And if you're a content creator, you can use quotes to see who's plagiarizing your content.
Also Quotes kennen wir, glaube ich, noch alle.
Ja, Jaffa, gehst du weg.
If you only want results from the site, enter your site colon URL.
Ich glaube, das kennen auch noch die meisten.
Dass wenn du was suchen willst, dass du eingeben kannst Site und dann die Domain und dann woran was sucht.
Das kenne ich zumindest noch.
Ich glaube, das haben die meisten auch schon gesehen.
Aber es geht noch viel besser.
That's also really useful for tracking down a result you saw on GitHub or Stack Overflow in the past.
Sometimes when you search though, the results might be dominated by one popular related topic like jQuery,
the king of the JavaScript frameworks.
You can exclude a term from the results by simply adding a minus in front of it.
Ja, das kenne ich auch noch.
That's also useful for eliminating unnecessary terms like your own custom class names from an error message.
Now, if you happen to be getting a lot of results about jQuery,
they were probably written many years ago.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ich wusste, dass das geht über das Menü und es macht wahrscheinlich das Gleiche,
aber ich wusste nicht, dass man dahinter schreiben kann after Doppelpunkt 2020 oder before 2020.
Das ist tatsächlich, gerade wenn man News sucht oder so, ganz praktisch.
In which case you only want results before a certain date.
It's also possible to search a range of dates or any number to that matter by putting two dots in between them.
Das ist mir komplett neu.
Das ist mir komplett neu gewesen.
Range Operator in Google, habe ich noch nie gesehen, wusste ich nicht, dass das gibt.
... from a legacy React project and you're comparing Svelte with SolidJS.
Use the pipe operator to search for one or the other.
Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass du das machen kannst.
Das ist ja schon fast reckergestellt.
... to group it and then apply another search term along with it.
Another Google search operator that seems kind of useless at first is the wildcard.
You might use it to search how to design an anything with Tailwind,
but it can come into play with other operators like site,
where I'm adding it here as the subdomain...
Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass das geht an der Stelle.
... that live on fireship.io.
When searching a site, I might also want a specific file type.
Das wusste ich für GIFs, dass es das gibt, aber ich wusste nicht, dass man beispielsweise
einen File-Type-Doc machen sollte.
Sollte man vielleicht nicht machen, aber das wusste ich nicht, dass das geht.
... in a regular Google search, or maybe I only want GIF files when doing an image search.
The file type operator makes that possible.
But what if you're like a black hat hacker that wants to...
Oh, Hackermans.
... like how to do sequel injection, how to hack the software on birds,
or maybe you just want to learn how they film the moon landing.
For this kind of stuff, Google results are carefully crafted to gaslight you.
Gaslighting doesn't exist, you made it up because you're f***ing crazy.
... to pierce through the establishment...
... to establish...
... to out...
... to...
You'll need to use a search engine like DuckDuckGo, or go directly to alternative media like Odyseur.
... DuckDuckGo supports all these things.
Wie heiß' der da? Attila Hildmann?
Ja, genau.
Ist das nicht da, wo der auch soein Zeug hochlädt?
Oder nee, der hat da eine eigene Seite, ne?
Nee, das war was anderes.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
war was anderes. Der hatte doch irgendeine eigene Seite, weil der nicht... Vtube! Genau!
Vtube war das, wo sie ihn jetzt gehackermanned haben.
Alles klar.
Nein. Ich mach ab und zu paar Videos, das reicht.
Das könnte ich beispielsweise auch gar nicht.
Das mit Cache wusste ich. Ohne Scheiße, da findet ich ein paar gute Tipps dabei!
Da findet ich ein paar gute Tipps dabei.
Äh, was?
Laut ihm sind bis Ende September alle Geimpften tot.
Ist aber nicht mehr so lang.
Müssten da jetzt nicht langsam die ersten Mal abkratzen?
Ich meine, bis Ende September, das ist ja nicht mal viel.
Das sind ja noch 10 Tage, 11, 12 Tage.
11 Tage.
Bist du geimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft.
Sogar doppelt.
Und es ist schon 4 Wochen her oder so.
Also 11 Tage noch.
11 Tage noch.
Aber vielleicht haben sie das auch verschoben,
wie auf dem Battlefield-Release.
Like und unsubscribe.
Ja, das solltest du.
Du solltest immer liken und subscriben.
Das heißt, du kannst das eine nicht ohne das andere machen.
Aber natürlich, wenn du das eine nicht machst,
kannst du auch das andere nicht machen.
Also es ist alles oder nichts.
Am besten auch comment, like, subscribe.
Ja, hast du auch gehört.
Das haben sie doch jetzt verschoben.
Ich werde hier nichts leaken.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr als das,
was man offiziell gesagt hat dazu.
Ich hoffe nur,
dass ich das demnächst mal anspielen darf wieder.
Äh.
Nicht wieder.
Also dann.
Weil das.
Ja, egal.
Die dritte Impfung soll kommen.
Danach sollte der Schutz ausreichend sein.
Ja.
Nein, ich habe nichts geleakt.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich habe mich versprochen.
Ich habe das noch nicht gespielt.
Ich hätte es aber quasi bald spielen dürfen.
Aber jetzt nicht.
So.
Mach dann in Zukunft deine Katze den Stream.
Vielleicht.
Chico-Stream gibt es dann.
Chico-Stream ist im Endeffekt.
Sie leakt den ganzen Tag.
Da und der Chat muss sie füttern.
Da müsste man dann irgendwie so einen so einen.
Ich sowas bauen,
wo der Chat über Chat Kommandos Knuspelecken rausfallen lassen kann.
So nach dem Motto.
Wenn innerhalb von einer Minute mehr als 50 Mal Pepo Fett gespammt wurde,
dann fällt ein Leckerli raus.
Sowas müsste man dann machen.
Ja, das wäre eigentlich mal ein cooles Programmierprojekt, oder?
Das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Ist eine gute Idee.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Hang zur Spieleprogrammierung, echt nicht innerhalb von einem Stream ist die Katze dann mega Chonker.
Die ist schon ziemlich, ziemlich Chonker mittlerweile, aber es geht.
Also die ist jetzt nicht nicht Hyper Chonker, aber die ist schon.
Na, hier sieht man es.
Hier sieht man es nicht so, aber die Chonkert schon ein bisschen.
Ich poste.
Ich poste zu wenig Bilder von der Katze.
Ich gerade hier.
Hier sieht man es ganz gut.
Also da.
Der.
An der ist schon ganz gut.
Aber es ist dran.
Ich müsste das dann aber mit Subscriber machen.
Alle, alle fünf, alle zehn Subscriber fällt ein Leckerli für die Katze runter.
Hast du immer noch das iPhone 6S?
Nee, ich habe ein 11er mittlerweile.
Davor hatte ich ein XR, davor hatte ich ein 6er und davor wahrscheinlich ein 4er.
Weiß gar nicht.
Nee, für Channel Points nicht.
Für Channel Points geht das nicht, weil für Channel Points, da verdiene ich ja nichts dran.
Wenn schon, weil ich muss das ja.
Ich muss ja gucken, dass sich das lohnt.
Ist seine Katze geimpft?
Nicht gegen Corona, nee.
Findest du Android kacke?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe auch genug Android Geräte.
Ich habe eh viel zu viel.
Ich glaube, ich habe elf Tablets mittlerweile.
Äh, nicht elf Tablets.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich glaube, die Smartphones muss man mitzählen, dass ich auf elf komme.
Elf, elf Smartphones und Tablets.
Weil sich das über die Jahre dreht.
Weil sich das über die Jahre so angesammelt hat.
Davon ist weit über die Hälfte, ist Android.
Schon gewählt.
Ja, ich habe schon gewählt.
Briefwahl.
Ich habe den Markt gewählt, dass der das regelt.
Ja.
Android zu deploaten.
Also ich habe, ich habe Android, ich habe da nichts großartig deploated.
Ich habe auf meinen Amazon Tablets, die sind ein bisschen älter, die verwende ich als Home Automation Dashboard.
Da habe ich Custom.
Custom ROM installiert.
Gut, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Vielleicht machen wir nachher noch eine Runde ProGas-Stells, weil ich muss unbedingt mein Heizungskram fertig machen.
Also Heizung, Heizung ein-ausschalten über Home Assistant.
Wie es prinzipiell funktioniert, haben wir das letzte Mal, äh, ansatzweise probiert.
Aber ich muss endlich mal was Fertiges basteln.
Du hast ein Shadowban bekommen, wo?
Bei mir nicht.
Na, das ist doch ganz klar.
Das ist doch ganz klar.
Der sagt, es gibt noch viel zu tun an den Stellen, wo es der Markt noch nicht regelt.
Das ist doch logisch.
Hast du eine gute Wandhalterung?
Ähm, ja.
Meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage-Telefone.
Ich kann die genau zwischen Wand und Telefon einklemmen und die halten bombenfest.
Gut, Leute.
Ich gehe was essen.
Ich habe Hunger.
Schön, dass ihr wieder dabei gewesen seid.
Falls ihr nicht auf YouTube oder Twitter am Start seid, könnt ihr bei mir auch vorbeigucken.
YouTube ist aber ein anderer Channel.
Twitter, hier und da.
Wer Bilder von meiner Katz sehen will und dummes Zeug, was ich so schreibe.
Discord, Ausrufezeichen, Discord, Discord haben wir auch.
YouTube, Twitter, ich müsste mir mal so ein Link-Tree oder sowas anlegen.
YouTube, Twitter, Twitch, Discord, alles am Start.
Was ist das?
Ah, geschälte Tomaten, nicht geschält.
Ja, das habe ich nicht verstanden, was mit denen los ist.
Könnt ihr, könnt ihr mein letztes Video über die...
Oh, das hat aber nicht viele Views gekriegt.
Was ist hier los?
Die Bahn zieht nicht mehr so, glaube ich.
Oh, da sind so wenig Views.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was ist da los?
Heck, wait.
Warum hat das jetzt 17k?
Ja, die Views kommen später.
Huge Joke, ich weiß.
So, ähm, der Rap war richtig.
Leute, dieses Video ist der beste Beweis, das muss ich jetzt einfach nochmal erzählen,
für euch, für euch im Stream so als Insider-Information.
Das Video ist der beste Beweis für, dass jeder Voll-Depp, ähm, Hip-Hop-Texte schreiben kann.
Es gibt doch hier irgendwo das, wo ich Haftbefehl zitiere.
Okay, Max, ist gut.
Hier, hier, hier.
Haftbefehl, Moment.
Danach ging's.
Ich bin dann an Willy-Brandt-Platz ausgestiegen, dann zur Goethe-Straße und, ja, so wie Haftbefehl das quasi schon ganz früh wusste,
der hat ja mal gesagt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton.
So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Es hat keiner gemerkt, dass das gar kein Haftbefehl-Text ist.
Nur der erste Teil ist von Haftbefehl.
Der erste Teil ist von Haftbefehl.
Den Rest hab ich einfach so dazu gebastelt und niemand hat gemerkt, dass das nicht Haftbefehl ist.
Wo wir wieder dazu kommen, Texte auf diesem Niveau kann jeder schreiben.
Das ist einfach kein, das ist keine Kunst.
Das ist das, warum ich ja normalerweise auch keinen Hip-Hop mag, weil das meiste einfach immer so, so skill-los wirkt.
Nicht vom Aussprechen, so die Texte, die sind, die wirken einfach so als, weiß nicht, als, als kriegen die Leute keine, keine gescheiten Sätze auf die Reihe.
Die Kunst ist, wie er es rappt, nicht wie er es sagt.
Ja, das lass ich mir gefallen, ja, das lass ich mir gefallen, ja, wenn's, wenn's um die Aussprache, die Betonung und den, und so Flow geschieht.
Das lass ich mir gefallen, aber es wird ja oft mal so getan, als sind die Leute, also die krassesten Big-Brain-Dichter.
Und das ist es einfach nicht.
Über die Qualitäten, das, wie sagt man so, Deliverance, sag ich gar nix.
Aber irgendwelchen Hip-Hop-Texten da großartige Genialität andichten, ist einfach lächerlich.
Will nicht sagen, dass es keine Ausnahmen gibt, gibt bestimmt auch ein paar Sachen, die sind ganz, äh, die sind ganz nice.
Genau, machst du Fax, mach ich die Plasmid ein.
Äh, der Anfang ist, der Anfang ist...
Der Anfang ist original, der geht aber anders weiter.
Äh, Haftbefehl, Pumpgun, Goethe-Straße.
Ne, Goethe-Straße, den schreibt man übrigens gar nicht mit Ö.
Ah, Goethe-Straße, hier.
Das ist, das ist das Original, hier.
Und der Rest geht ganz anders weiter.
Ich kann das nicht, ich kann das nicht, äh, jetzt nicht anmachen.
Ja, aber, bester Be...
Bester Beweis wieder für...
Diese Texte kann jeder, kann jeder schreiben.
Es ist überhaupt nix dabei.
Ne.
Das war nur für das Video, äh.
Dashcam-Empfehlung, keine Ahnung.
Gut, Leute, also, jetzt mach ich mich vom Acker.
Gibt's irgendjemanden, den wir hosten können?
Einer irgendwie mit nur wenig...
Ist der, ist der on?
Dann...
Oh, der macht bestimmt wieder abgedrehtes Zeug.
Foto-Boot mit Thermo...
Booth mit Thermodrucker.
Okay.
Wir raiden ihn.
Raid.
Oh, big, big brain.
CSS-Time.
Gut.
Done, Leute.
Lasst, lasst ihn mal raiden.
Was spammen wir?
Das könnt ihr euch selbst überlegen.
Ich vertraue auf die, äh, Spam-Qualitäten des Chats.
Also, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.